shaken no loops I got you I got you hello hello everybody
hey guys oh my god it's been so long since I've I've
streamed I need to remember how to stream how to tell
stories that's where I get baited um I need to remember how
to tell stories and how to talk to a screen it's been a
while I've had I've touched grass yes um surprise I've
returned with milk Who's this person in my subscription box?
And I've seen her in my life.
It's been one week.
That might as well be 20 years.
Welcome home, cheater.
Like, oh my God, Zachra, thank you for the 50 gift and
chips.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
Let's see.
That's not home yet, by the way.
uh i was like i gotta relax after coming back from vacation
i don't want to go scooping some poop right after um so he's
still at the dog sitter uh so it's just me right now it's
just me uh but missed i really did miss streaming i really
miss you guys a lot i have a lot of stories to tell you guys
a lot of stuff i know i said also many thank you but five
give the shifts thank you thank you Thank you.
Thank you.
Welcome back, Doki.
I'm back.
Next.
Thank you.
Thank you for the, uh, thank you for the super chat.
I missed you guys, too.
Um, bite size.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
I needed that vacation though.
I, I really needed.
Okay.
For those who didn't know why I was gone for so long and
being like, who's this girl?
I'm in my subscription fee.
I don't remember her.
She left for so long.
Who the fuck?
fuck is she uh yes i rested very well i mean like i was gone
for like what more than a week um i extended uh those who
didn't know i got invited by well i didn't get invited i
fucking won the trip like if i extended my stay because i
was like i want you know i want to like do more stuff than
just the capcom cup so i wanted by the way it's the 21st so
that means i can actually show footage of stuff that I took
from Capcom.
I know.
It's so awkward.
It's so awkward how the pay-per-view thing came out.
I was like, oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm coming back a few days after.
Then the hate will die down.
Because I was like, bro, it's gonna be so weird being like,
thanks, Capcom, for the invite.
While everyone was like, I hate you, Capcom.
I'm like, oh, shit.
Okay.
I'll come back a few days afterwards.
And then the hate will die down.
So people are gonna be those people are gonna be less mad so
I can talk about this trip a bit more positively like I
gotta wait until the fire dies down before I can talk about
it and also it's the 21st which means I can now everyone's
talking about Alex and the fact that he's fucking his cousin
so I'm like that's better you know like people are
distracted pocket sad Alex bucks his cousin like for those
who don't know um for those who are out of the loop and I'm
jumping everywhere there's so much stuff I want to talk
about but they released a new character also he married her
and now they're having a kid together but they released a
new character and they sort of recond his entire story where
um he has this little his has Originally, it was his little
sister.
And then apparently in the newest street fighter, they
reconded his little sister to be his cousin.
His second cousin, by the way.
Not his direct cousin, but his second cousin.
I don't know how this works, but like, because I don't know
about all these like different types of cousins, apparently.
And because of that, they're like, it's okay.
It's his cousin.
So they can get married, I guess.
And date and shit.
And they grew up together, by the way.
Some...
They grew up together, by the way.
Like, he held her as a kid.
And that's everyone who's like, bro, what the fuck?
I'm talking about Street Fighter.
Street Fighter 6.
Which is where...
Which is why I got invited to.
Not invited to.
I won the trip.
Sorry, I keep saying invited when I fucking earned it.
Like...
And then...
So they got married.
um they got married and they have a kid together now so
that's the whole thing now everybody's distracted about that
instead of the whole other thing instead of the other stuff
to be distracted by about capcom so thank god for that thank
god it's it's and then like people there were i thought it
was really funny because on twitter um on twitter people
like Alex was you before I like freaking out about that so
it's pretty Twitter is pretty funny right now regarding the
Alex situation um that they give us super chat thank you
thank you Brady they give a super chat thank you thank you
sweet home Alabama also congrats on 900k views for
girlfriend they give us super chat thank you thank you oh my
god happily hit 900k while it's gone but thank you guys
thank you guys for such a huge support on um the cover video
for uh girlfriend i like i said legit never thought it would
i'm working on the spotify release by working on a message
today about what to do like i know i could have done that
earlier but i had so many i literally i went off the grid
well not off the grid i post like i tweeted photos of what
the fuck i was doing um i did not check up on any work
stuff.
I legitimately, I did not check up on anything regarding
work related stuff.
So when I came back, people were like, um, Toki, um, um,
Toki, um, you're sort of behind.
I'm very much behind.
And I was like, I could have started yesterday, but instead
I went, I slept the whole day yesterday and I played
Overwatch.
Yeah.
Priorities.
Am I right?
I'm not though guys I'm masters two on overwatch I came back
I came back from vacation I went I slept 14 hours and then I
booted up overwatch anyway we're playing overwatch rank next
week and I played overwatch for like six hours and then went
back to sleep so so he looking so good for me right now I
should really get back on to work um six freaking of course
i'm back guys i'm looking back i'm back on the grind but not
the work grind is the why is she like this um um anyway
where was i uh fuck there's so many things to talk about
already lost track uh sir jett thank you for the five gift
of ships thank you thank you uh simple minded they give us
Super Chat, thank you.
Reunited feels suspiciously like trouble.
Thank you, Super Chat, thank you.
Um, I haven't checked out the newest Marvel Rivals season
yet.
Well, I mean, I was on vacation, so I quit it.
But, like, uh, but, uh, I mean, I don't know.
I heard, like, there's three bands each team.
Everybody's just banning support, and apparently all the
supports are just like, what the fuck do we do?
So, but I heard Overwatch, the reason why I came back to
Overwatch was while I was on vacation, I saw on Twitter that
people were saying that Overwatch has hit, has breached the
top six most popular games on PC right now.
So I was like, oh, that's interesting, you know?
Like, I was just like, oh, the popularity for Overwatch is
like actually coming back, you know?
So I was just like, you know what, fuck it.
Let's just move it to a try.
Like, let's get back in the ring and learn the game, like
relearn the game.
There's so much, I feel like I'm, I feel so washed.
I was just like, there's so many newfangled tech and
everything.
And I was just like, I feel so fucking washed right now
trying to relearn everything.
But I'm getting better.
Like, like, the things I used to know is so different than
what is currently the meta.
Like, what you have to do at the moment.
Because they changed a lot of stuff.
They, you know, they added a lot of things and changed a lot
of stuff that I used to know.
And, um, and then I'm just hard to, and then apparently
Kierkegaard's been meta for like 800 years.
So I've just been like trying to learn how to play
Kierkegaard again.
Fuzzy, thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Holy shit, I'm so jealous.
You gotta hang out with Kenny Omega.
Tell me you gotta watch him do some wrestling.
Fuzzy, thank you, thank you, thank you.
You know what's funny?
I had no idea who he was when I got here.
At first I wasn't gonna meet him because like the staff, for
those who don't know, Kenny Omega is a wrestler from AEW,
which is like the opposite of WWE.
So like, it's their like rival companies.
And it was so funny because like the staff at first was
like, do you want to meet Kenny Omega?
And I was like, I don't know I don't know who he I was like
I don't know who you know who he is I was just like I was so
scared at first because I was like I don't know who he is
though like I feel like it'd be so awkward because like I
had I was like literally googling him and like Wikipedia
Kenny Omega because I was like I was just like oh my god at
first I said no and then I was like I just know he's a
wrestler that's all I knew I just like oh that's the like
what I remembered about Kenny Omega was what you guys told
me when we watched the game awards it was either one of the
award shows it was one of the trailers shows you know I
forgot it was either the game awards or the summer fest
where he like was cosplaying a bunch of rest like a bunch of
street fighter characters and that's the only thing I
remember about Kenny Omega because you guys are like it's
Kenny Omega and I was like who the fuck is this guy and I
was like oh that's silly look at him dressing up as all
these characters um and then and then during yeah during at
the when i was there i instantly was like googling him and
wikipedia him trying to like know who he is because like i
was like and because like i said no at first and then later
on um i was like you know what i should take my shot you
know i should just meet him even though i don't really know
who he is i feel like he'd be a very interesting person to
me and he's like really he's like really well known in japan
he's really well known like around the world in the
wrestling community so i was just like you know i'm you know
what i i i i should meet him and so Like I went out of my
comfort zone to like To like meet up with him and talk He's
so cool He is so fucking cool Um he is so good at street
fighter too Yeah apparently he used to live in He lived in
Japan for 10 years Um he used to live in Japan for 10 years
He actually is quite He's like semi fluent in Japanese by
the way Um but oh yeah also the photos I'll upload So I can
show you guys so for those who didn't see on Twitter uh let
me download the photos real quick and show you guys he's so
fucking cool uh oh i also got his autograph too i didn't
show this on twitter but i'll show you guys this let me
check for reflection um i'm downloading i'll give you you
guys some pick and you used to do wrestling japan i actually
asked for some like suggestions on like uh here you go
here's kenny omega Yes, I gave him naked Proto-Doki to hold
on.
There he is.
Kenny Omega, for those who don't know who he is.
Also, guys, thank you for Magenta Super.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki Prime.
I gave him Proto-Doki slash Doki Prime for one of the
photoshoot.
Glad you're back and managed to not stream mid-vacation rest
or prop.
I was, I was, I brought my laptop and everything.
Getting ready.
brought my laptop my whole setup for no reason my keyboard
my laptop my mouse for no reason my microphone um for no
reason and then it was just it was just like the heaviest
paperweight in my suitcase it even opened my laptop because
i was so busy every single day that i never had a chance to
actually like stream um uh anyway gus thank you magenta soup
but thank you thank you i can my birthday this week, but I
can forgive you.
You brought back milk.
Then you give them a janta soup, but they get...
Don't worry, I'll be... I'll go get milk after this stream.
Don't worry.
Then she never returned.
And then she goes to Japan again.
Because, um, don't worry.
I'll sing you a belated happy birthday song.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Gus.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Ivan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome back, Doki.
Did you need a separate suitcase for your Sanrio merch this
time?
Ivan, thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This time, I didn't buy Sanrio merch, though.
I actually fit everything in my suitcase in a way where I
had to carry two extra bags.
But I didn't have to get another suitcase, though.
I didn't take any photos of all the stuff I got, though.
So I'll do that maybe during the stream.
It was crazy.
I went to the Pokemon Center and I was, I think I beat
capitalism, guys.
I think I'm getting better at beating capitalism because I
didn't buy anything at the Pokemon Center.
I went there, I looked around, and I didn't buy anything.
Anyway, I went after I finished the Pokemon Center.
I bought a few things at the store next door.
But, but I resisted the Pokemon Center.
There were other side of Pokemon but I resisted the Pokemon
Center um it doesn't count it doesn't count the the first
part counts and then the outside part doesn't count um yeah
a win's a win I resisted the Pokemon Center okay it's baby
steps one step at a time anyway so um and I also I I got fat
Pikachu.
That was the one thing that I've wanted to get.
But they don't sell at the Pokemon Center.
They sell it via scalpers.
But they have scalpers in Japan.
But it's still cheaper than getting scalped by in America.
It's still cheaper than getting scalped in NA.
Because I don't have to buy shipping price.
It was like $100 cheaper, apparently.
That's the only thing.
because i used to actually i used to i used to like it's
absolutely it's crazy it's still like a hundred dollars
cheaper than buying it from like online or buying in america
um and i don't have to pay shipping prices that's just like
a hundred it was like what two it's two hundred dollars
right wait let me google it fat pikachu buy let me google
that real quick yeah apparently buy it online it's like 187
to 200 plus dollars not including shipping if you want to
get fat Pikachu and for those who don't know what fat
Pikachu is it's the original it's like the 30 year um it's
the 30 year anniversary um and actually I used to own this
plushie as a kid um because my parents bought this for me um
and I actually used to own it so it was more like nostalgia
for me like that's like the only thing I really wanted
because it was like nostalgia uh but this is the fat Pikachu
that everyone was like trying to get for the longest time
and you can't get it at Pokemon Center because it's not
released by Nintendo it's released by Takura Tomi so this
was like they re-released it basically they re-released this
Pikachu plush um recently I don't remember it was like a
couple I think like a month or two ago and the oh and I
actually used to own this so it was more like So I, yeah, I
don't even know what happened to it because it was like when
I was like a little kid.
So big chungus.
Yeah.
So I really wanted it because it was like nostalgia and it
was something that I had as a childhood.
So I was just like, I have to get it.
Like I had to get also I was freaking it.
My water bottle like fell on my keyboard and I was like,
fuck.
Like I hope it doesn't accidentally press anything.
Anyway, so I bought it for how much?
much was it let's see i don't need to convert it to i bought
for a hundred dollars versus 200 which for me i i was just i
i stood outside this store where it was obviously selling
like scalp shit like you know products you wouldn't find and
like regular like for retail anymore so obviously they're
pricing like higher and everything so and i stood there for
so long like Debating whether or not to get the fat Pikachu
because I thought they only had one left because it was just
there It was so when I bought it and the other guy came down
and put another fat Pikachu down And I was like fuck.
I was like, it's like the FOMO.
They were artificially giving me FOMO Um, I literally got it
off the shelf paid for it headed out of the store and I saw
one of the staff member Came in with a new fat Pikachu and
put it back in there.
They got me.
I fell for it But like, I debated for so long on whether or
not, whether or not to get it.
It was, because like I said, like I knew I wasn't going to,
it was on the last day, the day I was about to fly out.
And I debated for so fucking long on whether or not to get
it.
Like, I looked at it and I was just like, I don't know, man.
I don't know.
It's still a lot more expensive than retail.
And I went and grabbed Revolving Sushi.
baby versus like do i you know like put my hands on my head
and was like do i get it do i oh my god should i should i
get it like i was like i'm just like oh my god do i get the
fat and i called my friend she was like i don't know man do
i get the fat pikachu it's like right there but i know it's
so much it's more expensive than retail but like but it's
fat pikachu though it's it's like so fat like and then my
friend was like i'll just get it bro just like i was like
but but but it's like it's it's 800 it's 100 but it is a
hundred dollars but it is a hundred dollars cheaper though
and i was like you don't fuck it it's like then don't get it
i was like oh but i should i what if i never see fat pikachu
again what if and then it was calling me like the green
goblin and then and then i was like no i'm gonna do it i'm
gonna fucking do i'm gonna get it i'm gonna get it and i
back to the store and grabbed it i so so i got i got fat
chunky pikachu um uh i just yeah i just called just wanted
them to just say just make the make the agreement for me but
they weren't like super invested into my decision so it's
like i don't fucking know just if you want to just get it i
don't know he's like just don't get it i was like no you
don't understand i was like i wanted them to be more
committed in the decision and giving me the decision i
wanted um anyway so okay so sorry let me start from the
beginning let me start from the beginning before like my
youtube channel dies up before my career dies because i it
was scary being gone for so long because i know like i don't
know i have to like slowly rebuild again but like i i needed
this vacation um i really
nice it was actually i want to make this tweet before i did
the stream um but uh because you know when you're gone for a
week plus it's like you're gone for 20 years on the internet
so so um i gotta be more consistent again um but like it was
oh my god really fucking neat i want to make this tweet
before before i did the stream but like i i took a huge step
in towards what being more social for vacation because like
usually I don't meet other content creators because I'm just
like, oh, you know, I'm just like, oh, I just meet with
people that I just meet with the staff or like, I don't
usually don't even take these types of trips.
I was not going to go to Japan for the Capcom Cup thing
originally, my first, this, my originally when I first
joined this tournament, but I worked so hard winning this
tournament that I was like, fuck it.
For those who didn't want, watch it it was the new
challengers i won all my matchups and i worked so hard i
like sped run learning honda in three days so um for those
who need like a little recap for everything um i didn't do
sang deep this time because i was like i it was just i
wanted to like win against my opponents as fast as possible
in the cheesiest way i just wanted a noob stomper and then
my coaches were like you should do honda and then i sped run
honda i literally went from silver to platinum in three days
um and i worked so hard using my brain and played that in
like in that in that tournament we played for seven hours
straight with a two hour like one one to two hour gap
because we got into the finals i'm about to wait one plus
hour i was so fucking tired and i had a headache and i was
sleepy i was so eepy and i celebrated with hot pot right
after winning anyway i was so i was just like i have to go
to japan after that like I had to go, I had to go to Japan
after that because I was just like, I worked so hard and I
was like, at this point, I'm taking this as my fucking
reward.
Like, so, so I said yes to the trip because of it, because I
was like, this was too much work that I invested way too
much work into this to say no.
I earned this and you know what found out on the trip.
I was third pick in my tier I found out that because it was
like the coaches picking and stuff.
I was third pick and I was like fuck you guys Third pick
Swipe wiped out my whole division steamrolled my entire
division for being third pick
The...
Not last picked up.
Apparently, Emily and Faisy were first pick.
Brodown was last pick.
Then I was third pick.
I...
No.
That's right.
Third pick.
I steamrolled an entire division.
Not last pick and made the...
That's true.
Not last.
Not last pick.
Like, I took, yeah, I took that third pick personally.
I was like, I was third pick?
Took you.
No, the thing is, I found out on the trip that I was third
pick.
Because I was just like, because my teammates were talking
about, I was like, yeah, I was the first pick.
I was like, wait, what pick was I?
I, you know, in my head, I was like, I had to be first pick,
man.
I had to be.
I mean, I'm competitive.
I like, I sort of played this game before, before I
installed it after the first T-Jet Slown.
I, I'm committed to it, sort of.
And then to find out, I was third pick.
It's okay.
We won.
We were first place in the end, though.
We were first place.
in the i earned those points i earned it i um cas thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you um um okay to be fair
to be fair maybe not as committed as i should have been
because i found out about this i had an entire month knowing
about this tournament and then i spent three of those no
okay not entire month maybe like maybe like two weeks it was
two weeks i knew that was in this tournament for two weeks
and i spent a week and half of those playing marvel rivals
rank instead of playing street fighting and then i cram
sessioned and sped run with the last three days till the
tournament to learn honda but but I did learn him I if I had
those two weeks it wouldn't have been fair guys it would
guys just remember if I used those two weeks to learn Honda
it would not have been fair so I just made it more fair for
the rest of the people in my division um
I was trying to be more fair to everyone guys guys thank you
for the super chat thank you yeah i made it more interesting
um very proud of you man go catch those breaks and have a
good time when you need them thank you the super chat guys
thank you thank you thank you cody thank you the super chat
thank you thank you it's my birthday thank you for always
making my day brighter in every version of the dokey verse
it's crazy that god hang out my goat kenny omega much love
and big bear hugs Thank you, a super chat, Cody.
Thank you, thank you.
Also, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Cody.
Yeah, happy birthday.
All right, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh.
Adio, thank you, my magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, the stone cold Steve Austin bird.
What I'm gonna have a beer.
Thank you, the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, so yes, I took, um, I took the Capcom Cup trip to
Japan.
Um, so it was basically, uh, it was originally we were
supposed to leave on the 16th.
I think, yeah, it was, but I extended my trip a couple more
days because at first, I was like, at first, um, I thought I
was gonna do other stuff other than watching Capcom Cup
because I thought like, because like the only days that they
saw what is there was uh the finals uh all of thank you for
the five give the shifts thank you thank you so the finals
for the street fighter league and the finals for like the
individual like um the division the the capcom cup thing but
in the end i actually went to capcom cup the tournament
venue like all days because it was actually really fun i
thought i didn't enjoy land but i think it was just i didn't
enjoy shooter lands you know i didn't i i really enjoyed the
street fighter lands because it was insane it was so intense
like the um we were in we were in a sumo arena um so like
you know like that like the arena itself was like a sumo
arena and then so it was like you get to sit across um it's
a different vibe for sure the only the problem i have with
like um lands regarding like fps or third-person shooter is
that there's so much wait time there's so much like what's
the word for it um there's so much like um like just nothing
going on for so long until the last 10 minutes um so yeah
downtime there's just way too much downtime i've had i've
had it in like apex i've had in rivals i had in overwatch i
feel like um there's just way too much downtime and then
like um not enough like prep prep stage going in um like i
know like overwatch and rivals there's like you know there's
not as much time as like battle royales and stuff so but it
just it doesn't give off the same like intensity that it
does with like fgc so like it was my first time watching a
fgc at in person and it was crazy it was actually so there's
like i'll show you a video for it it's like there's a lot of
stuff always happening did i play i fought i didn't fight
that we had a moment when we were all meaning when because I
wanted to meet Kenny Omega and then um we dragged along uh
so there was only three of us as me Emily and Feisty um
Verdun couldn't make it and Nephew couldn't make it um oh it
was so funny we all thought Nephew was gonna make it but
then apparently he did like because like Capcom apparently
what I was told was that um our uh Capcom thought Nephew was
our coach by the way was gonna qualify was gonna qualify in
Capcom Cup so they're like it's alright we don't have to get
him a ticket because he's gonna qualify and then he didn't
qualify so then he couldn't make it I get him bro
so I was just like oh my god so I was so I was just like oh
my god yeah so nephew wasn't there our coach wasn't there
and so because i was like guys hey where's nephew and then
the staff was like um we thought he was gonna qualify so i
was just like okay guys why is it just us three where's
nephew where's our coach
so that's that's like it wasn't there that's like he wasn't
there so i was just like Oh, it's okay.
He didn't watch fine, either.
He did, uh, he did a little, he gets to, yeah, so it was
like, girl, it was girl's night, uh, plus one of our staff
members, but it's okay.
Like, it was like, it was technically girl's night, because
he's gay, the staff member that accompanied us.
So it was like, girl's night, technically.
I don't, the, the staff that handled us.
um okay let me hydrate real fast
okay i'll like jump between stories so um let me show you
guys another picture so um i met kenny omega uh uh and uh
and the staff wait let me double check yeah this photo all
right So as you guys see here, it's Kenny Omega with one of
the main, so there's three of the head devs.
And this is one of, like, there's the, um, for Street
Fighter 6, there's three head, this is the head marketing
team for Street Fighter 6.
Another human, welcome to tomato farm, welcome, welcome.
So, um, Kenny wanted me to take this photo of him.
By the way, he's a master player.
He's like basically a master Elo in FGC.
Street Fighter 6.
And he wanted me to take this photo.
And this is like, when we all met him, we were just like
chilling, talking, hey, yeah, then he, uh, apparently that
dev wanted, challenged him, uh, challenged, that's feisty,
by the way, that's feisty.
She was our top, she was our top player on our team.
So she was like, um, she literally won us the trip during
the final match.
Uh, she's crazy insane.
She beat Kenny and the dev, by the way.
Um, well, Kenny beat her once, but she won twice again like
won one set on her but she won two sets on kenny and then
also she was i think she won she won i don't know i don't
know if she drew or like she drew or won against the dev uh
but she's insane um she's insane in street fighter uh and
she's a kimberly player um anyway so um everyone like had a
little fight like you know like because the dev challenged
kenny um in street fighter and so we were just chilling
hanging out and then we were all just like talking and stuff
and uh and we're just hanging out talking and everything um
and and then the dev was like i'm i want to challenge you
kenny to a street fighter match um and uh and then they're
like doki you should play too and i was like no i'm just a
casual i didn't play this game for four the new challenge
like i'm sorry guys i have installed street fighter right
after new challenges i was like i'm sorry i haven't played
it so i haven't played it in four months and then they're
like i was like and they had like pads so i was just like i
was just like i was saying a newbie I told him like my strat
was that I was just like my strat was I want to stay like a
new player so any other future tournament any other future
tournament I can be drafted as a new player so I'm eternally
a always a new challenger so I can always be a new
challenger every time I always want to be like emily so for
those who don't remember emily was the tier above me and
like that could and then she had to fight jps um she had to
fight jp i'm not exactly i'm not leaving my elo i i don't
want to leave my elo i'm so scared because emily was a tier
above me technically and then she was fighting master
players all night all during that entire tournament and she
was like the diamond player and she was playing masters
player and now i was re-watching the tournament and then and
then she was fighting like jp players and everything and i
was and i remember i was re-watching he's like that could
have been me i was like she was not having a fun time i was
like i did not think we were gonna win i did not think we
were gonna go to japan after what i had to deal with and i
was like i'm so sorry emily i re-watched the vibe and that
Like, that could have been me if I kept playing.
That could have been me.
I was like, I'm so sorry you went through that.
That looked horrible.
And she was just like, I was like, that was so, it was so
bad.
It was so bad.
Observe, peers, go.
Surprisingly, when JP is in Japanese, he's not as annoying.
I don't, I think it's because I don't understand.
what he's saying but he's not as annoying as english jpeep
also um yeah so i was just like i won't say it my elo i i
don't anyway so um back to the story um um i said oh i play
on leverless because they were playing on pad at first and
then the dev was like don't worry uh don't worry i can um
street i like like watching street fighter but like i'm so
scared of playing street fighter like i think street fighter
has made me the most mad out of any game street fighter and
split tune it just it brings this anger in me because like i
can't blame my teammates i can only blame myself like
anyway um uh and and so he was like don't worry I can find a
leverless and I was just like no it's okay it's okay I don't
want to fight I'm sorry I'm really bad I'm the beginning I'm
in the beginning here I'm a touch street fighter in for in
in for fun oh my god fuck okay um and he was like don't
worry I can I can I can bring a leverless and then and then
he like came back he came It's basically a street fighter
controller with no lever.
Um, and then he came back with the lever list.
And then he was like, you can fight our social media
manager.
Like, who was the staff that handled?
Who was basically the staff that was had, like, I'll show
you guys photos.
You're going to see him.
Um, because he said it's fine.
But basically he, he's the social media manager in, in U.S.
He's the U.S.
social media manager.
So like, uh, basically also I peer pressured him into
following me, um, on Twitter.
like the Street Fighter, the Street Fighter account.
Basically, the whole story was that.
What's that?
When we were there, we noticed, me, Emily, and Feisty,
noticed that the Street Fighter account was not following
any of us, but it followed our coach and Frodo, who were not
there during the Japan trip.
So we were like, why aren't you following us?
like well I led the charge I I let the charge and then he
was like why aren't you following the account because he
looked up me and then the other two girls were it and I was
like I only follow back I was like I only follow back and
then when he and he's like okay fine I'll follow you guys
and then he's like and then he's like why is she still not
following back afterwards and i was like well it took you
this long to follow me so i guess i'll make you wait a day i
was like well you took so long to follow me i'm gonna make
you wait
anyway anyway so i fought him in street fighter um because
like the dev was like it's okay you too and then like he was
like he was like i can't i haven't he was like i haven't
touched ranking so long um in a while or like also a couple
of months because um i am following now am i not no i am i
remembered because i remember i actually did follow back
after a day or two yeah i'm following them i got baited i
thought i was like no i swear to god I was following so
basically he not just handles uh and then he was like he
didn't want to fight me either because he was like he was
like I was like I was like I have nothing to lose because I
was like that's fine I'll fight the social media guy because
he um he also hasn't played the game in a while he like he
said he touched plat and then didn't and then he didn't play
after he didn't play a lot after that he still plays but he
didn't play a lot after that um but he had to spend like
working on the marketing, the social media for Resident
Evil, because he's in charge of all the social media
accounts under Capcom USA is run by him.
So he is the one that posts all the thirst traps of Leon.
So you see all the thirst traps on like social media from
the official accounts, they were all done by him.
Like,
and then he was like, I was like, I have nothing to lose.
everything to lose if he lose against me so that's why he
didn't want to play me but i unfortunately got absolutely
destroyed because i did not um i had like like i re-binded
some controls but i forgot what controllers i re-binded i
forgot i i don't remember on top thank you for the five
gifted chips thank you thank you and then the leverless
controller that they brought me it had no symbols on it like
you know how i would look down on my controller because i
used the razor one and had the symbols drawn onto the
controller so it didn't so i forgot what did what and also
where the fuck my hands are placing at so i was just like i
was just like i and also i did not find my drive impact so
so i was just like i was like wait a minute i drive impact
and the devil's like we could stop and find it now it's like
it's okay i don't need it because i knew i was gonna get
destroyed i was getting destroyed anyway so i was like it's
like yeah i don't need it i don't need i need my playstation
symbols and it was doomed and also he plays jp so so it was
over like who the fuck i did not see any jps during my run
to plat because i that fucking learns JP in the beginning
will just speedrun all the way to like high elo so I had
like no knowledge of how to fight JP because like I swear to
God no one plays JP in the baby elo no like I bump into none
of them I feel like they all they like you get them at that
starting at diamond so it was over it was so bad I was just
like I don't fucking know what to do I was just like I was
like there's so many things going on my screen pierce now
observe pierce to observe and i was just like i'm like okay
obviously i didn't win but i knew what i was getting into at
the start like i said i had nothing to lose i had nothing to
lose with that with that um also my main monitor is off
right now because like it's doing like the little repair
shit right now i forgot to turn that shit on so i i can't
show any pictures at the moment because my opus is So I'm
waiting for my monitor to turn back on right now so I can
show pictures of everything
No, don't worry you guys are on my you guys are on my third
monitor Um, I didn't get sick.
I didn't get sick.
I just talked a lot.
It's been a while since I talked a lot So my throat is was
like My throat is like not used to the whole talking thing
again talk this is the first time i actually met other
content creators um that i never met before in real life you
know especially like flesh tubers so it was a huge step for
me because like i said i always like i'm super careful and i
met a lot of people like i said i would never i think in the
past i would not like try to meet up with like kenny omega
and all these dev people and like i met so many like staff
members too and um and everything i met i did i did meet up
with mint like it was we there was a possibility where we
never even got to meet up um oh wait my mom's back yay it
was really rough because she was really busy and i was like
she was more busy than me obviously because she had she was
doing a lot she got sick she was like behind schedule
because she got sick in the first week and a half um and
like literally it was like my last my last two days of the
trip where we were able to meet up um and everything um and
um and also yeah so so she was very very busy but like for
good reason i saw like the stuff she was doing and it's
pretty cool it's really cool whenever whenever you guys get
to see it it was very worth it the um worth doing all of
that in japan uh gordon thank you the super chat thank you
thank you happy to have you back toky can my best bud can
you give my best bud john get a happy birthday today he lost
his fictional wife in the divorce he was being too freaky
with with other fictional women
don't worry no leaks no leaks but it's it's just really
fucking cool uh no work don't worry Gordon, thank you for
the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, John.
My condolences.
A great thing about fictional women is that there's a lot of
them out there on the internet for you to discover.
So you always get a chance.
Bro, don't worry, bro.
John, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear John.
Yeah.
happy birthday there's a lot of fictional fish in the sea
exactly oh my god i said i was going start from the
beginning but i it was it was all over it was all over the
place um next seat they give a super chat thank you thank
you i'm glad you're still able to meet up with men and women
so sad to both be in the same city and not hang out i saw
you went to your collab cafe too yeah she invited she
dragged me over to her collab cafe as well um the next day
um um or i don't remember it was like yeah like on my uh so
she she also dragged me to her collab cafe as well on um on
my last day like right before i was about to leave uh and it
was really good it was really it was really pretty too it
was like um what the funny thing about it is that across the
street uh was an olaf statue and it was so fucking creepy
Apparently, it's been there for several years.
Oh, by the way, I think I beat it.
I don't know.
Okay, maybe not.
I'm too scared to try it to test it out.
But I think, guys, I think I can eat strawberries now.
Because I swear to you guys, it was like 70% of desserts in
Japan.
is mostly strawberry based but I ate strawberry ice cream
and I was all right guys I think this Japan trip I've
actually leveled up my immune system how did I find out
there I ate straw it was there was strawberry on the collab
cafe so I was just like I was like um I was like I'm hungry
I mean okay I didn't fuck okay I want my brutal honesty on
on the collab cafe menu I didn't fuck with the cheese on top
of the hot cake like the Japanese hot cakes I didn't fuck
with that the cheese was just not it for me I just I I
didn't want like savory shit on my dessert so yeah I risked
it all because I was hungry uh but the thing is I the
strawberry was just like um was just flavored strawberry or
actually strawberries i didn't obviously i didn't try the
fruit i didn't try the fruit on the dishes but i tried the
the strawberry ice cream so yeah so on top of the hot cake
um i didn't there was cheese on top of it i didn't really
like it that much i like the hot cake itself just not the
cheese part um so um don't worry It's not like really my
adjoys not bad where like I need an epi pin It just fucks
with my I just get go up with hives.
It's just my it's just exterior Like my skin just goes up in
hives like my face and my hands and everything it get itchy
and stuff Um, so other than that it was other than that it's
fine and I had the mango drink because like all the other
shit Um Was like I was like I'm sorry man.
I can't have like it was like the mint Theme drinks was like
it was like coffee and juice and i'm like i'm sorry man i i
i do not want coffee right now and i i don't i i just don't
like raspberry so i got the i got like her mama's drink
which was a mango juice i'm like i'm sorry man like i can't
i can't drink out of this like
next see they use super chat thank you thank you um expire
from eating strawberries will have the end of time please be
careful they even super chat next to you they get thank you
um and she's like that's understandable that's like um all
right let me show you the olaf statue i was gonna show you
guys that let me find it too oh yeah also let me that i all
right the kenny uh i had to check reflection not check
reflections i took more than 400 photos i was actually a
tourist here i that just took more than 400 photos crazy i
was like uploading it all to google drive because i was like
i'm not gonna do this i usually in the past what i do is
that i would just do it like 10 by because like the maximum
amount pictures and videos you can upload on um on discord
is 10 each and i was like i feel like i took a lot of photos
i'm just gonna like just dump it all on google drive just to
see how it goes and thank god i did Because it was a lie.
It was absolutely.
I died.
I took a lot of shit.
Where is this photo?
Where the fuck is this photo I took?
It's not.
I hate it when the files don't sort by.
Like, sometimes it doesn't sort by recent.
So I'm like, where the fuck is the autograph?
Okay, five.
It's so annoying.
Okay, five, six, four.
What the fuck?
i said download why didn't download my picture my where is
the picture now i'm downloading download this wait this is
absolute oh my god downloaded like two to i down wait what
what the fuck is h-e-i-c okay i don't know what is this file
high efficiency image container however it's a smaller it
uses advanced compression oh my god wait give me a sec
claudia welcome to the tomato farm welcome welcome why the
fuck is it high efficiency image container why how did it
get there okay i'm forcing it into a png yeah but usually it
just gives me into a jpeg or a png so i don't know why i
didn't convert it That was weird.
All right, here we go.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
What happened to it?
Like, what happened to it?
It cut itself.
What the fuck?
Like, oh, I can't just rename.
Okay, 2PNG.
I wanted to show you guys the autograph.
Oh, yeah.
I asked him for, like, wrestling.
So, for those who didn't know, he, uh, Kenny Omega used to
wrestle in Japan before he came back to AEW.
So he wrestled in Japan for like 10 years.
And that's why he's really famous in Japan.
And I asked him for like wrestling show recommendations.
Because that's like one thing I really wanted to experience.
I didn't get to go though.
I had no time.
Like all the wrestling shows.
Apparently he told me to go to like Shinjuku.
What's it called?
Was it the face place?
Shinjuku Was it Shinjuku face Told me to go there Because
that, um And he also did like Deaf matches and stuff He used
to do a Deaf match there Um It was Apparently there was a
Deaf Um I couldn't go Because the Uh Because All the days
Where there was a wrestling show Um I I I was gone I wasn't
in Japan Or like I missed it Because of Capcom Cup Um And Um
You should do an AEW WrestleTuber.
Guys, I don't think there's an AEW Wrestle game.
If there was an AEW wrestling game.
Maybe.
I don't think there is right now.
During like the.
With the amount of customization that we need.
I don't know.
The thing is.
We need like.
The stuff we need for that.
There's.
There's not enough like.
It's just.
Not as good custom.
Yeah.
It's not as.
good you know you know what i'm saying the game is like the
customization and the uh the stuff you can do is not as good
as the stuff we can actually do um yeah um anyway um as i
was wait where was i as i was saying okay yeah but and he
was talking about his time in death match i did not this and
he was saying deathmatch for those who don't know uh is
actually crazy so there's this thing they do in Japan um and
because there was a deathmatch but it was like after I leave
so I couldn't go there and like his manager and him were
telling me to go check it out and it's crazy because it's so
it's like real blood like it's like you think it's fake but
like they go so hardcore there and and it's like it was like
super insane and he was showing me videos of it of like
these guys that was actually like bashing each other with
real weapons it's called death matches in japan and and like
this guy they showed me a video uh there is an eight but i'm
saying that the game doesn't offer enough customization and
like visuals as well as the other games that's why i was
like it's a little hard and i feel like his contract with
aew might like you know because we're using wwe game it's
like conflicts interest and stuff like that which is the
which is the unfortunate part i don't want to like risk
anything with that um all right thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you I feel like if it's like Yeah, so Anyway
Anyway What was I saying?
Oh yeah So they showed me a video Of it and it was like They
got like a bunch of A bunch of This guy, it was like two
Wrestling wrestlers and he got a bunch of Sticks and then he
spashed The sticks into this guy's Forehead and Kenny was
like, that's real.
Like, I was like, holy fuck.
I was like, this guy's forehead.
He's like, that shit's real.
I was like, what?
It's so funny.
And then selling us, they don't play.
They don't play.
Like, it's not fake.
It's actual fucking.
Like, their backs are all scarred up and everything.
Yeah.
and and he was saying like they they like been doing this
for so long that everything is just scarred up and they
don't feel anything anymore because uh because like they've
been doing this for so long so their backs were like all
okay and then and then he was saying like yeah the barbed
wire is real they like they like they so there's another
footage that he showed us where the guy was like slammed his
back against barbed wire in this greatest entire back so his
back was all bloody and everything and he was like yep
that's real barbed wire and i'm like that's so metal that's
crazy i was watching the video like they were showing me
like videos that they were recording and everything i was
like oh my god
yeah can you apparently he's popped his eardrums like three
times like both his ears to a point where he can't wear
earphones anymore he can't wear those like earbuds because
they fall out because his ears don't hold them in anymore
like i was like jesus christ bro oh my god but then he's
like But he's made it, you know?
He gets to chill now.
He gets to be one of the Dreamfighter hosts.
Yeah.
Bro, yeah.
Like, I was like, that's a thing that happens where, like,
you pop your eardrums so much that, like, your ears just
don't hold in the earbuds anymore.
It just slips out.
It just, no, he's, no, he went straight right after.
right after the tournament he flew straight back to LA uh
for an AEW event and I was like respecting the grad I'm like
bro I respect it I was like yeah no he literally right after
he went straight back in to do AEW shit like bro fucking god
I respect that grind yeah um I'm bro that's crazy that's
actually what I found I was like holy shit this is crazy
shit all right let me show you guys the autograph shout out
to Kenny for the autograph it was really nice meeting him
he's actually he's such a nice guy he was the one that
recommended us to see punch the monkey too uh because he saw
punch the monkey um it was like you guys gotta check it so
cool he's such he's so nice he's such a humble and he's such
a really he's he's a really nice guy like ira um but yeah
there there's kenny omega's autograph see to dokey bird
goodbye and good night bang i'm really glad i got to meet
him um um but yeah he was the one that recommended us to see
punch the monkey uh because that he saw punch the monkey
earlier and so like he was like you should check up punch
the monkey and so we did um fuck that monkey because okay um
I was stupid because there was like people were like like uh
the like Emily um all right his name is Andy uh the social
media guy um Emily Andy and Feisty were all just like queued
up waiting for the monkey and I got tired because I was just
like he's gonna be a while till this fucking monkey shows up
so I I'm gonna go check out the other exhibits because I was
just like it's gonna be a while I was like you guys will let
me know when they when he shows up right because I just want
I want to look at the other stuff and then so I you know I
went and saw like the lemurs and and he showed up he fucking
showed up and I was like we're out came back I was like
where are they and I didn't know because nobody I swear to
God I was close by to hear people be like wow my punch it's
like apparently And I came back, I was like, where did they
go?
And I texted them.
And they were like, oh, yeah, we're at, we're at, we're,
look at the orangutans a bit now.
And I was like, what?
I went over there.
And then they were like, yeah, punch came out.
And I was like, what?
So it was like, it did take a while.
They waited.
Look, the thing is, they waited like 30 to 40 minutes
waiting for Punch the Monkey to show up.
Like, they were patient.
I was not patient.
and now i was just like i'm gonna go you guys just hold my
spot just let me know i think i can hear and then they
forgot about because they were so like oh my god he's here
you know they forgot to like message me because like he
showed up you know and then they were like in the moment
like adrenaline came in and was like god see anyway so
obviously i was like i have to see punch the monkey too you
know like i i i have to see it like i paid for the uber here
I was like, I paid for the movie.
I have to see it.
Like, so I was just like, I'm sorry, guys.
I felt really bad because I had to wait on me.
But like, I'm so sorry.
I really need to see Punch the monkey.
So I waited there.
I stood there for an hour.
I got for another additional hour waiting for that fucking
monkey to show.
up and it was it's crazy because there were rules there that
was like oh um um please only if you see him just you have
to leave like after that you got your moment like 10 minutes
after you see him you have to like let other people uh have
a chance to see him like get in front because it's like a
little i'll show you let me see if i can show a picture of
this it's actually let me find a picture it's so dumb anyway
nobody fucking followed the rules there was this girl who I
was in a position the punch of monkey came out like two
times.
The first time the first time I couldn't see him Because
like the area standing in was so like there were people in
front of me and then like I couldn't see shit And then I
looked to my right and I saw this lady She was so fucking
greedy because she still she stood there She saw him she
recorded him She was like oh my god there's punch and she
stayed there because she wanted to see him fucking greedy.
You're...
I was like, I was like, you saw him, you recorded him, and
yet you're still in that spot.
Here's the good spot.
Like, because, okay, so there, like, here's some context.
It's very hard to see him because, um, um, because there's
like this area where the is like the backstage area and like
like where it's all covered up except for two tiny doors
like it's like the stone wall basically except for two tiny
doors in the wall and um and uh apparently punch loves
hanging out in the backstage area not like in the uh in the
backstage area not like actually out in the open so it's
very hard to see him because he's just chilling inside the
backstage room um so so um um so that was like a little bit
of an issue we had there yeah like it was like a private
space area so that's why he it was so hard it was so hard to
like see him because of it um how dare he be comfortable i'm
not saying his punches fall but but but that was the reason
why it was so fucking hard to see this goddamn monkey so let
me see if i can grab the photo let me see um let me see
where is the photo i took of this thing all right let's see
let me make sure that all right all right here you go i'll
show you oh so this is basically what the okay i'll show you
guys is what the arena looks like like the monkey pen um
anyway when i finally wiggled my way into the front i saw
him get punched and i was he fine i had to wait a bit i
wiggled my way to the front finally after i don't know like
15 minutes in the last 10 minutes he found like or like 40
minutes and I waited another like 10 to 20 minutes and he
finally showed up because everybody like there he is there's
punch there he is and I was like oh and I'd be like stood up
on my tippy toe shrine and grab footage of punch and I'm
like I'm like saying oh my god and then I saw him and then
another monkey rolled up and fucking punched him and I'm
like he deserves
don't you became another you got exactly what it said i got
that monkey i became a hater that day i mean it's this name
it got what you got you know you got you got what you were
going to get trying to see punch the monkey um but I became
his auntie I waited so long to the point where I became his
auntie and you don't understand I sit there for a fucking
hour I that's like it was like god damn god damn monkey uh
anyway what they don't tell you what they don't tell you
about is that he outgrew the plushie he doesn't give a fuck
about the doll anymore so like like apparently um the other
the other three they didn't see the doll but i saw it
because like because apparently they're like yeah i didn't
see punch holding on to the they didn't tell you they don't
tell you these important things that's the only that was
also the only reason why i wanted to see punch the monkey
because i wanted to see him hold that's what made him
special i don't care that he's getting mean I do care but
like I don't want to see him to get bullied but everyone's
like oh it's so cute and he holds his plushie that's the one
thing I wanted to see but sit out and saw it's just this
fucking regular monkey like getting getting punched like
yeah he's like a teenager right now apparently he has
apparently he has a girlfriend now the girlfriend looks like
the plushie or some um yeah so it's like i was just like
he's just a regular monkey like he's just like the thing
that made him special was because he was holding the plushie
but now he's just a regular monkey that gets punched i was
just like i didn't want to wait an hour to see that guys i
didn't wait a fucking hour to see a fucking money monkey get
beat up anyway so um anyway so the others they didn't see
the plus sheet but i saw it because um it was one of those
moments where i couldn't really see punch but i saw the
zookeeper feeding um yeah it's like moody but no one but
then leaves moody no one talks about moody anymore because
she grew up like she's not cute anymore which is pretty sad
but that's that baby animals for you um anyway even punched
a monkey guy girlfriend before me many thank you with his
super chat thank you thank you anyway so i saw the plushie
because apparently he doesn't give a fuck about plushie to a
point where he chucks it across the pen where it's like in
this ditch and the zookeeper was like going up to the like
going to the ditch and picking up the stuffed monkey to put
away it's like because like and then but like punch had
nothing to do uh nothing to do with the plushie literally
they don't tell you that they don't tell you that he agree
with like so so the zookeeper was picking up his toys and
stuff and i saw the plushie but i'll show you the picture of
it or the video of it um all right here this is what i
wanted to show you guys what is this resin oh yeah uh let me
say if i downloaded the video okay it's this so this is what
the pen looked like um if it's loud i'm sorry oh my god it's
the wrong way
give me a second let me flip it uh rotate okay i've rotated
wrong let's see rotate 180 there we go so this is what this
is what the pen looks like.
It looks like this.
So you see that it's crazy.
It's actually crazy.
It's like...
Okay.
Loop.
It looks like this.
So it's like a circular thing.
And then everyone in the front has to... This one I actually
got a good spot.
So it's like that.
It's basically like that.
Like how it looks.
I fucked it up.
Yeah.
Why are you filming vertical because i i i don't know man i
i just wanted this i filmed everything in vertical yeah so
it's a very it's very small like uh but anyway there he is
wait where there he is why is it all h-e-i-c i think it's
because i took too many photos i i think i took too many
photos um all right let me show let me convert this real
quick convert
to hold that is true it is easier to hold the phone like
that all right wait is that a random monkey i can't tell
they all look the same now to me they all blur together i
don't think this one was punch this one okay i did see him
guys everyone pointed all the japanese tourists pointed him
out for us so like this is just a random monkey but you know
here here's a picture of a random monkey But you can see the
door.
You can see...
This is where...
You can see the door also in his ass.
You can see the monkey asses.
All right, let me find the video of Punch real quick.
Let me find the picture of Punch real quick.
Oh, there he is.
Look at him.
He's such a loner.
It's so sad.
He's such a...
Like, we're all just seeing this sad monkey.
Like, being a loner.
It's actually so sad.
like okay I'm downloading it all right let me see right here
like there he is there he's just like there he is that's
that's punch that he's pretty tiny like but he grew the
plush like like he's just like you know he's so It's been
sad as it is It really Help him He has a girlfriend Does he
really need help now?
He's like
Look he made it He got a girlfriend now guys He has a
girlfriend He's made it A cameraman does nothing again He's
still pretty small but he I'm not outgrew like i said he
actually outgrew the plushie he doesn't carry it no more let
me see if i can find punch forgot where he came from shake
my head papa thank you super chat thank you thank you next
see thank you for the super chat thank you thank you let me
find this video i took when i finally saw the fucking monkey
let me see when i saw him get punched
okay you're gonna hear me talk because i was desperate i was
just like so happy when i finally saw him i let me see where
is it all right here we go all right let's see let me turn
down the music and then uh where the fuck okay there it is i
think it's here okay
i think i found him he's real i waited 40 minutes to see
this goddan monkey but punch is finally real he's is he
getting beat up my god he's real he's actually real
i think i found him he's real i waited 40 minutes to see
this goddan monkey there you go there he is dude he pulled
him over oh my god he's sitting on him too He's real.
He's real.
He's not like that monkey was grooming.
And the other monkey literally ran up to him and pushed him
down.
Like he was trying to get, look, look, I'll do a little play
by play.
He's like getting groomed at first.
The other monkey shows up.
He wants to get away.
It's like, you're not getting away.
He pushed him down.
And then he stands on top of him.
he's trying to get away he's
and this is where i finally saw him i'm gonna come give you
guys a play by play i wouldn't not done yet it will not do
something camera man
why did you um i wasn't even in the front row yeah it was me
trying to take a video and like from behind two people with
my camera like extended above my head like don't you you
just yeah and and 500 other people too we all if you're
gonna blame me blame the 500 other people that also just
watched that it is a cruel world yeah it was like the
bystander effect right there um
anyway after seeing punch the monkey i don't would you say
uh was the trip where i mean after seeing the monkey getting
okay okay i That poor child I saw something exciting I guess
Was it worth An hour wait though I would say Not really
Finish that sentence You can't I will say It was not worth
Standing there an hour Also lives in japan people people
really like it was a thing that we all kept seeing like
everyone was like oh my god like it's all lines we're like
i'm pretty sure you can spend 70 of your life in a line in
japan i'm pretty sure it's like no it's crazy okay there are
so many lines there was guys so many lines.
I'm not that strong enough, guys.
It's like New York City where they just, where people just
queue up for lines and like sometimes it's worth it.
Sometimes it might not be worth it.
It's just there's so many.
There's so many.
No, it's like, it's, it's like lines for a bunch of stuff,
but it's like, I don't want to wait three hours.
I'm sorry.
Like I'm not that strong enough like my feet hurt my feet
hurt my feet really hurt and okay so i'm gonna jump to
universal i know it's crazy um mint was like i asked if she
wanted to do it and she's like you're fucking crazy for that
because i was like i'm gonna do it i'm a speedrun universal
studio i'm just go to osaka take a three-hour bullet train
to osaka at um um starting at seven in the morning go to
universal studios finish universal studios come back take
another three hour bullet train back by the way i did not
realize how expensive bullet trains were until i got there
that might have been poor planning on my part but i just
tried to speed run universe she's like no i'm not doing this
i was like all right we'll meet up another day because my
initial plan was like we should do universal together it was
like feisty joining but yeah i was crazy it was i spent a
lot i don't think okay so no i went on a tuesday i need you
guys to know this i went on a tuesday for universal studios
and i thought i was safe because i was like weekday it's a
weekday their spring break hasn't started yet i assume no
hadn't yet, but, and, and it was a Tuesday.
I was wrong.
I, I, oh my God, there were so many lines.
There were lines to, to leave the ride.
I, I was like, I'm leaving the ride.
Why is there a line to leave the ride?
I, I'm leaving.
I'm done with this ride!
I'm done!
I'm...
Oh my god.
And then, okay, the worst one was the Mario Kart one.
Guys, I don't know what day is the perfect day to go to
Universal Japan, but apparently it's not Tuesday.
Because, I swear to God, during my time at Universal, I
Googled four times, is it a holiday in Japan?
And every time I Google it, I don't know why I still don't
trust this.
I, I was like, are you sure?
And then they're like, there's no holidays right now.
Starts next week.
I was like, Google, are you?
I like, throughout the day in Universal, I was just like, is
there a big holiday right now?
And it always tells me, no.
But for some reason, I never believe in.
So I have to double check.
I Anyway, so Apparently some schools in Japan Take their
students to Universal Japan Like I was like bro what the
fuck Bro what you get to go to A school trip to Universal
What
No The thing is Majority people there in Universal Japan Was
like Because like Golden Week starts next week And like, it
was mostly like Japanese attendance.
There were not a lot of foreigners there because Spring
Break hasn't started either.
So there was like mostly like Japanese residents at
Universal.
And then, so there were like students there.
There were students there.
And then the crazy part was I saw students not in uniform.
So I was like, you guys, I know there's...
school day i know there's a school day so why the fuck are
you here
okay so i was like you're playing hooky i know you're
playing hooky
because i saw school kids and you're not wearing your
uniform anyway i was so mad at these particular group of
teenagers because i was lying i went to the monster hunter
cafe because um it was the last day of the monster hunter
cafe um and and i was so and i was like looking forward to
it because it was last day and it was like super cool okay
by the way let me it was last in the month i'll show you
guys a picture of it it's so cool um the food was really
good too uh let me find the picture real the food was so
good i watched i watched so much i'm so tired the moment i
got home and start sitting down i was just like oh my god i
was just like oh my god this feels amazing like sitting down
the concept of sitting down it was felt amazing i i was just
like oh my god i love sitting down um let me find the
picture real quick oh my god it's all like heic usually i
think when i upload it on discord like it automatically to
PNG but for some reason this one doesn't it's so weird let
me convert this real quick Google Drive doesn't like when I
got up my feet hurt so much now like it's just like the
backs of my feet hurt a lot let's see like the not like the
souls hurt.
Not like the, uh, let's see, five, eight, nine, seven.
Okay, there you go.
Not like my legs hurt, but it's just the souls of my feet
hurt because I put so much pressure on it when walking.
Yeah.
I don't have any blisters or anything.
Like, it's like the back and front, like where it's like,
uh, yeah, I like walked a lot.
Anyway, it looks like this it's so cool i think this is so
cool here this is what it looks like it's like the front on
the monster hunter cafe so it's so cool like the front of it
and um here's one with my plushie i love carrying this
around look there's me right there they're so cute right
here They're so cute.
Look at this.
It's so cute.
Anyway.
Let me.
Oh, yeah.
And then I got the potion for this.
Look, there's little dokey.
I'm right here.
And she's gonna burn.
That's me.
I'm right here.
Oh, my God.
I saw a strike, by the way, too.
I saw a strike at Universal.
It's, oh, my God.
She talked to.
It's like Feisty and I were trying to get.
Okay, by the way, Feisty also came with me because I was
like, I want someone.
Like, I wanted, I didn't want to do Universal by myself.
So I paid for Feisty's trip because, like, she's planning on
staying there for, like, she's staying there until Evo
Japan, basically, and she's going to go there again.
So she was like, oh, I don't want to go because I don't want
to pay for twice because Universal is so expensive.
Anyway, but I was like, no, my treat because I didn't want
to go by myself.
Anyway, we couldn't get a photo with Shrek because he was
like, those goddamn group of kids stole Shrek from us.
They stole Shrek from us, so we couldn't get a photo.
Anyway, yeah, so she's staying that long in Japan Fudge
stop, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you
Yeah, I hate it when your feet become so sore after so long
The best way to release some pain from it Is to, okay Fudge,
thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you Anyway,
all right Back to what To, I'll show this, I'll keep this
picture up Back to what I mean by Fuck those kids But like,
you know, not really But at that in the moment I was mad
okay I was mad at these kids playing hooky because um anyway
so I knew they were ditching school because I was like it
was a group of teenage boys and we were I was waiting and I
was like oh feisty you go you go grab a table you'll grab
the table and then um and then I'll line up like it's the
line at that point was doable at like because we went
straight to we arrived because we got there around like 11
ish almost 11 and then we went straight to like to like at
that point lines didn't get that intense yet so i was like
you go grab a table and then i line up and then i was like
oh i'm getting there and then these group of there was like
seven of these boys seven of them i counted and the thing is
they tell you okay this is a little bit i this is the one
thing i like had my biggest gripe because we're i feel like
we're missing some steps here um like this could have been a
perfect system and and So they let you scan this.
They tell you to scan this QR code and then order online.
And then when you get on the register, you scan the QR code
and then autumn and then you just pay.
But those boys did not order, did not scan the QR code and
ordered.
cash the ordering system the cash register and one by one
and not as a group by the way not as a group one by one they
were deciding on what to order they're like do i get i was
like you had so much time and then feisty texted me and was
like you could Like, what's going?
Because I think I waited in that line for 30 plus minutes,
15 of which is those group of boys.
And then it got so bad because we were just halfway done.
We were just halfway done from this group of boys that one
of the staff members came over and was, like, sticking the
QR code in front of all of us.
it helps with efficiency and then they were just came like
please do this scan this QR code and then like the thing is
two I was like a third one left after that because like I
was a third in the line two other guys we did the QR code we
all had our phones out getting ready to scan it and the
group of fucking teenage boys and I swear to God I was
watching one of them press the fucking cash register the
ordering machine and i swear to god he was so confused i
knew they speak japanese too because i heard them yap for 15
minutes in that line and and there he was just like oh
and then beep
beep Wait a minute, a guy!
Oh my, they were teenagers!
You can't even say they were little kids!
They were teenagers!
And then, oh my god, I was just watching this kid trying to
fucking order from their mission.
And then, oh my god.
And then, when he was about to pay, he, like, was like,
where do I put the cash in?
And, what the hell?
I was having a breakdown watching this.
And, and, and, and, oh my god, and I have to wait for this.
I have to wait six.
other boys do this.
There's only two machines.
And they did it one by one instead of ordering as a group.
Because, like, I assume they're like, oh, you know, we each
pay for our own meal.
But I was like, you're a group.
You're a fucking group.
Just order together.
Oh, my God.
Anyway, so, so, anyway, um, I feel like we're missing a
couple of steps with this QR code I feel like I feel like if
we're gonna order online we can order online and when it's
done we go to the counter and pick it up I feel like that
solves a lot of stuff you know like if we're gonna introduce
ordering online we I feel like we're missing like step three
and four and then went back to step minus five like
Because I was like, I was saying this to Feisty.
I was like, we're going to fucking order online with the
option to pay online.
Why can't they just give me a number after I order online?
I sit on the table and then I wait for them to splash a
number and then I go pick up the food.
I don't understand why I order online and then I still have
to line up.
What's the point?
If I'm still lining up and still ordering online, the line
must somehow still exist for some reason.
I was like, why do we need to have lines if we're ordering
online?
Why do we, like, it's just like, we gotta have a line.
We just gotta have a line.
And then after you like, it's just, I just line up to scan
my QR code and then line up again to get the food.
Like, like, I just, I, I don't understand.
I still have to line up twice, guys, because I still have to
line up to scan my QR code and then line up to get the food
after scanning the QR code.
Oh my God, sorry.
Sorry, no, you don't understand, like, all these lines
fucking broke me.
I there were so many lines like I will line up like there's
you can't avoid it you don't understand that was like my
breaking point during universal with all the that was my
breaking point like I I just I oh my god it was crazy I oh
the ultimate cue
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please understand there was no subway surfers or TikTok slot
playing underneath to keep their attention.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Damn toky making it sound like she went for it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh man.
Okay.
So there was obviously we could only do the black, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the, the attractions the rides where I
had the never go to universal without express pass.
I don't care if you're trying to save money.
There's no point you're gonna spend like you're good.
You can only I swear to God if you didn't get the express
pass you can only ride to get like rides.
That's it.
I bought the ticket the day before my like I bought it on
Monday because I saw there was still lots of tickets so I
bought it on Monday.
I didn't even care which I just wanted.
No, god like all the rides all the rides maximum was was
like a hundred two hundred minutes there's one of three
rides there's like a little app you get where you can see
how long the rides are and they update you the universal app
three of the rides was 200 minutes and you would just It's
just lining up and I don't it's not worth it.
It's not worth it.
I'm not sad.
Oh my god, it was a Tuesday It was a fucking Tuesday.
I don't understand it was a Tuesday.
I need to look it up I need to look up how many people were
there universal Japan Wait time.
I need to know what the crowd level was like I could there's
no I Oh my god.
I need to know what percentage that was I was trying to
figure it up, but like what was it oh my god did I I came at
a really bad time it was at 84% it was the crap it was a
Tuesday I should have I should have went on Wednesday the
thing is I wanted to go on Wednesday doable once they once
they would have actually been redo it there's no way i'm not
there's no way universal japan i don't believe this calendar
there's no way that i went through that there's no way i
went through that level of hell like okay no never mind it's
not that bad it was not that bad.
Okay.
I was, okay.
It was, it was a D level.
Okay.
I went with the, the other calendar was not as right as I
thought it was.
Okay.
That's fine.
Let me double check.
Oh, it over predicted.
I knew it.
Okay.
That was just a prediction.
It was an over, it was a D level, but it was not, it was
not, um, okay.
Okay, was that a...
Oh my god, this is actually crazy.
I can't believe.
I just...
I want to not believe this.
I...
I'm just like, there's no way...
Why was it that bad?
What the fuck?
I wanted to go on Wednesday.
I wanted to go on Wednesday, guys.
I okay all right it was an over prediction but I can't tell
if it was I can't tell I can't tell every website is giving
me different results chat every website is not giving me the
same okay crowd calendar I
googled I googled guys no you don't understand guys I
googled three times Is it?
Is it a holiday?
I don't understand.
Oh my god, I googled three times.
I googled three times.
I don't understand what the fuck happened on Wednesday.
Okay, I'm glad I didn't go on Wednesday.
Apparently Wednesday was also hell.
I don't.
I mean, apparently it was also as bad.
It was...
What the...
I don't...
I don't understand it!
It's a weekday!
There was no holidays!
What happened in Japan on
the...
Takes like one or four hours to get in, dressing up to
cosplay, also needs to queue up, taking photos of
cosplayers, needs to lie.
Zaka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't understand what was going on that week.
What the...
what was going on what kind of hell was i in anyway i was
just like it was not it was the worst time to go to
universal maybe it was the word it's right here this is
where the days i went to universal right here like what
happened i swear to god i googled i googled what holidays
were It's today a holiday in Japan.
I googled it.
Something was going on on Tuesday, apparently.
I'll fucking know.
Something was going on.
I just was not aware of it.
Anyway.
I did not eat any of the churros.
I did not eat.
Because every snack bar that was there, popcorn stand, snack
bar,
was a 30 plus minute line.
And I was not going to line up 30 plus minutes for a fucking
trurial.
I'm sorry, but I was not going to line up 30 plus minutes
for a goddamn trurial.
sure guys that like i had my limits
sorry i had i forgot but i turned my bgm back on um um so
like those little snack stands and everything i took i i oh
my god i chose the wrong day to be going to universe okay
holy fuck anyway so there were three to four lines there
were three four breaths that were like 100 190 to 200
minutes throughout the day by the way it never stopped it
never got lower it never it never got better i will say it
kept getting it kept um getting higher it was at first it
was 160 and then it went all the way to 200 minutes um and
um oh my god i still can't oh my god like what the fuck not
i'm like i it's hard for me to comprehend the fact that it
hit it hit that i don't know what the was going on that week
i swear to god the vacation didn't even i can't process it
the the vacation didn't even start yet it's like the the
japanese holiday starts week what do you mean what happened
like spring break starts next week like anyway anyway but I
still will say like it's not worth going there without an
express going there without an express pass because it was a
lot it was like like I said i was not i i think mentally and
emotionally i was just yeah the pre-gaming it was a pre-game
i was not ready for for how crazy the lines were um but the
only rides i went um was literally from my express pass so i
went to nintendo like the only thing i really wanted to do
was nintendo world anyway i didn't do the flying dinosaur
for those who don't that was the one that was like the 200
the 200 minute ride and i had a i had a express pass feisty
went for it and she was like that that doesn't look so bad
because it was a fucking roller coaster let me show you guys
what it looked like like the flying dinosaur it literally
makes it seem like you're flying apparently but i was like i
don't fuck with roller coasters as well so like like i i
just i didn't fuck with that like yeah I just didn't fuck
with uh with roller coasters in general and it looked like
one of the most intense roller coasters there so let me see
I saved let's see where this is what the roller coaster
looks like um it's like this it's crazy it's and then feisty
we would hear people screaming every time um i went to the
thing is i went to the universal in u.s uh a lot a while ago
and that had the the harry potter rides and all that stuff
so i've done those before uh back then in the u.s so i just
like i was like by the way ricey was like i really want
butterbeer because like and i was like sure let's go let's
go grab the live looped the butterbeer stall
three loops and i was like we're not lining up for that i'm
sorry feisty i for one one fucking plastic cup of butterbeer
i am not lining a looped line for that like
i i don't know it could have been an hour i feel like that
line would have lasted an hour
She was like, no, no, I'm not.
I was like, I hope you're not.
I'm not waiting an hour for you.
I'll fucking sit in this chair.
You fucking buy yourself butterbeet.
I'm sitting on this chair.
You're fucking lying.
This goddamn line.
It's like, anyway, anyway, so.
So, um, this is what the flying dinosaur ride looks like and
um it looks fucking intense because it's no it is fucking
intense every time we went past Jurassic Park um the section
we were just here screams like every time it's not like like
like weak ass screams it is like crazy ass I am gonna die
screams and it's like and it and it fucking shows up every
two to three minutes um Like, like, maybe like, like, three
to four minutes.
I just hear, you just hear it.
Like, all the screams come from this ride.
And I was like, I'm, I bought the ticket.
Like, my express pass includes this ride.
By the way, for those who are wondering, what rides did I go
on?
I went on Mario Kart, the Yoshi one.
Anyone, the Yoshi, by the way, the Yoshi Q-Town was 70
minutes.
And the ride itself, I swear to God, it was two minutes
long.
anyone that line up 70 minutes for the fucking yo I'm sorry
that Yoshi ride is one circle loop and you do nothing I mean
that's rise but it's like you sit there there's barely
anything there it's like a weenia junior shit the line is 70
minutes long we had the express pass we waited like 10
minutes at most I was like I I'm I was like I feel so bad
for anyone that waited 70 minutes long for this fucking two
minute long ride.
It was literally two minutes long for this Yoshi ride.
Anyway, back on this, Feisty was like, nah, that ain't too
bad.
I've done rollercoaster.
This shit doesn't look that fast.
I was like, I was like, I'm down to do the other roller
coaster.
The Hollywood Dream, like, but this one, this one looks a
little too intense for me.
I'm down to do that one because we had an express pass for
that.
and then and because like the the the normal wait time was
like 190 minutes and it was climbing up and she's like no
i'm gonna do this this looks like this looks like less
intense than the hot and i was like and then she got off the
lap like she got off the ride she's like oh my oh my that i
that oh my god and she's like just it's a lot faster than
you think it is
she's just like you don't the ride it's you don't you don't
realize how fast that ride it's like and i was like you want
to do the other she's like i'm good i was like i think i'm
done with roller coasters like she's literally i couldn't do
all i didn't want to do hollywood trees by She's like, after
this, right, she's like, I don't think I'm done with roller
coasters, dokey.
I don't think I can do another one.
Apparently, she's like, no, it's so fast.
She's like, no, you don't understand.
It's so fast.
It's like, I thought she wore her glasses.
She's like, she had to hold onto her glasses against her
face because she was like, I thought I was gonna lose it.
I thought I was gonna lose my glasses.
Like, oh.
Because she's like, she's like, really does seem like you're
flying it apparently um it apparently seems like you're
actually flying when you're on it so if you like roller
coasters um do but do not do the normal three hour wait go
grab the express pass for this by the way it's crazy these
press passes are so expensive there's one that you can get
six rides and that was like four hundred dollars mine was
like the cheap side like not the super cheap one but like
not 400 dollars per ticket per ticket for six rides of
express i'm like at home and that was sold out it goes the
most expensive i saw with the express ticket was like 700
for one ticket i was just like yeah it can be sold out By
the way, these tickets can be sold out These Carl, thank you
for this super chat Thank you, man, I can't believe Dookie
got to meet Kenny Omega In person, I'm so jealous I wanna
meet Kenny Omega in person He's so chill, he's such a nice
guy In super chat, thank you, thank you Carl, um I, no,
universal In, I don't remember which universal I think the
one in LA Uh, or Florida I don't fucking remember I don't
remember, I just went, I don't know, I went to I think it
was like LA or LA one.
There's a universe in LA, right?
Like, I remember.
It was so long ago.
It was like, like, back when Overwatch League was still a
thing.
I didn't, not, I just, not because I went to Overwatch
League, but I just remember the timing of that.
I just remembered when I went to Universal, Overwatch League
was still a thing.
Yeah, was it?
Yeah.
In LA, yes.
Um, I'd never had to line up those type of lines before.
Like, The one in the one in um in in America the lines were
a lot less worse than the ones in Japan.
Like I will say that like I could go just go go there and
just do a ride and then not have to not even need an express
pass.
It's just I'm just free to just go in there.
Um it never stopped the lines never stopped though like in
Japan all the way till nighttime.
it blew my mind.
I was like, surely the line will die down.
But, but then like, but then I, I swear to God, like it
closes at nine.
We had to leave before seven.
Um, because we want to make sure we get on the, I think we,
yeah, we left around seven-ish because we want to make sure
we, I think it was eight.
It was either seven or eight.
But, um, oh, I think it was eight.
We left at eight so we could get on the Osaka bullet train
back to Tokyo because I was just, speedrunning it um and oh
my god someone made a good point and american one's probably
bigger too no it's crazy nintendo world and donkey con
country small as hell it was like literally like i felt like
i was in an apartment uh the donkey con country one it's the
size of like an apartment like apartment suite like it's so
it's so okay maybe i'm exaggerating but when you go to
Donkey Kong country in universal Japan it is so small like
and we were like wait that's it we were like I swear there's
like four corners and then the ride the the mine cart ride
which by the way was 180 minutes long these people it's
crazy because like it's 180 minutes long so it was like 8 p
.m.
and they're still in that line hoping to catch one more ride
180 minutes these people were waiting for 180 minutes um For
the like for a bunch of them like four rides like I said it
never went down the timer never went down So they would wait
three hours like just before closing and then just in that
line and I was like They're so strong.
They're so much stronger than me.
I I literally did not do anything that was not in the
express pass You know what rides I did?
I did a minion ride.
I I did the minion ride.
I did the Mario Kart.
I did the Yoshi one.
And then I I saw Waterworld.
Waterworld was pretty cool.
Waterworld.
That was on the Express Pass, but I saw Waterworld,
including the Jaws, the Jaws ride.
But like, unfortunately, the Jaws ride was closed down.
It was closed down.
So I couldn't see the Jaws ride.
But then it was like you could do Jurassic Park but then
feisty told me in the Jurassic Park ride unlike the American
comparison of the Jurassic Park ride you get really really
wet and it was cold it was sort of cold at that time so like
the like because I remember I went to the Jurassic World one
in Universal in America and and you don't get that wet it's
not that bad like But then apparently in Japan it's just
you're drenched if you don't have your what even if you have
the The water the coat on like you get fucking drenched in
water and I was and she was like Oh fuck with that we're not
doing that.
I was like that's cool like I don't really want to get
drenched in water too like Like it's just it goes everywhere
and now it's just like bro.
What the fuck It's like it's a big ass splash apparently for
the Japanese equivalent of it like they don't hold gonna
like everything is gonna get drenched in water they don't
hold out um but that anyway that was my universal experience
will i do it again i i think i think i'm good i maybe
halloween but then i feel like halloween will be even more
messed up because like i heard the halloween event is like
the most fun for universal um and um that's like the one I
really wanted to go like because like I see was like are you
sure you want to do universal we could do Disneyland but
like I feel I don't fuck with current Disney at the moment
because like I don't current I don't really care much about
Disney right now because um how the new Disney stuff is like
it's so boring it's just really boring
So, um, I know they have the Frozen ride and then like the
Beauty and Beast ride, but like, I just don't, I don't care
much about, um, current Disney at the moment.
Because like, it's just, it's, I feel like Disney has been
pretty mid these days.
And like, I don't have the nostalgia feeling of like, oh,
Beauty and the Beast, Frozen and shit like that.
So it was like, oh yeah, I want to go over the Resident Evil
stuff, but have like the lines though.
and and stuff so it's like so that's why i didn't really
want to go to disneyland or tokyo sea and universe was like
the only amusement park i haven't been yet in japan i've
been to the sea i've been to disneyland but only when i was
a kid like when i was like 10 or 11 or some ship um so you
know obviously i had a lot more stuff now but like there's
nothing i'm like yeah disney you know i'm like oh my god
disney yeah like i don't care like merch stuff wise or
anything i don't care about duffy duffy um the bear like i
know that's too oh minions are so popular by the way minions
are insanely popular in japan i know they were really
popular but like it has hit a whole new level um it has also
yeah there's a lot of animatronics but also i have a huge
immense fear of animatronics in general so so like yeah
they'd be like oh but the animatronics though the
animatronics and the new new rides are insane like the
frozen you know when i'd make fun of the the old frozen
animatronics with the new one uh was it frozen which one was
it the new frozen ride frozen ride it was in japan yeah like
i heard like you know a lot of there's not some new rides
and everything but i was just like i don't really like
animatronics in general so i feel like it's just gonna freak
me out more than like actually like be like wow no during
like um uh like i don't know what was it oh my god like
seven plus when was the universal like the forbidden journey
like that ride a long time ago like seven plus years ago
forbidden journey with the dementors and everything and um
and like i closed my ass throughout that entire ride i
couldn't i do not i cannot do that i was with my i remember
i told you guys the story before i was with my friend and um
and and they were like oh they were like we have to do this
route we had an express pass we have to do this ride and
then like throughout that ride i closed my ass throughout it
because it was just i was so i opened my one second saw that
fucking dragon in my face close again never open my eyes and
then my friend was like we gotta go again it's so fun and
then i went with them again and then they were hitting my
lap be like open your eyes open your eyes and then i opened
my eyes saw the spider and i was like i don't fuck with this
i i was like i can't i don't fuck with this i i can't i do
not enjoy this again because I just don't I just don't fuck
with animatronics it's like what if apparently I didn't
watch a video of the ride before I went into it because I
knew there was animatronics so I went in there being like um
I don't have arachnophobia by the way I just don't fuck with
animatronics in general because I'm like what if today's the
day that these animatronics are I'm next you know I don't
they're like that's the day that's why I was just like if
I'm gonna die and these guys are gonna kill me I'm not gonna
watch this happen I'm closing my eyes like like if today's
that day where they gain sentience I don't want to see it
happening I'm I rather it's black like my eyes closed like
so um anyway yeah like Skynet's gonna happen and I was gonna
say um I watched a video of it apparently some guy at one
point because like you know rise can break down in some shit
um but I read a comment where they some was like the ride
broke down when they were at the dementors spot and they
were saying how like they were so moving and making the
sound so he was stuck there for 30 plus minutes while the
dementors were in his face and i was like oh my god i do not
i'm sorry i i hope that will never happen to me i i hope in
my life i will never have to experience that ever like
that's like what's the exposure therapy to the next low
that's just trauma right there yeah like that's that's
literally just trauma like um anyway that's that's a that's
a no for me that's a hard no um so So anyway, where was I?
Minions!
Um, they are so popular.
We were at a merch store.
Feisty and I.
And then, we saw this teddy bear.
And we're like, that is such a cute teddy bear.
And it was this teddy bear merch everywhere.
Let me see if I took a photo of it.
Because I was so confused.
I was like, where the fuck did this?
What character is this in Universal?
Like, what character is this fucking teddy bear?
grab the photos.
So, um, so there were teddy bear hats and, uh, wait, let me,
I know what it's called.
So I, I was so confused.
Like there were hats of it.
There was, um, there were like headbands.
There were plushies.
There were cups.
There were every types of teddy bear merch of this
particular teddy bear.
And a lot of, a lot of girls were wearing it.
Like a lot of were wearing that specific merch or carrying
that specific merch so we were so confused and then we read
we read the tag and it says Bob's teddy bear and then Feisty
was like who the fuck is Bob and I was like oh my god it's
from minions it's it's the minion that it's the fucking
teddy bears I'm Bob the minion oh I was like oh my god it's
the fucking it's the fucking teddy bear that he holds on to
so so it's this is this this is this is bob's teddy bear and
this this particular character is everywhere in universal
it's crazy i know i don't understand because it's just i
it's a teddy i guess it's cute i think like teddy bears in
general is just very popular in Japan because there's Ted
Ted is very pop for those who don't know Ted is just Ted the
Seth McFarland Ted is very popular in Japan there's merch of
it everywhere um um goofy the bear the Disney I the Disney
character um is very very popular as well um it's a teddy
bear as well um And it's like, they just love teddy bears.
And so, anyway, back on minions.
There's like people cosplaying as minions.
I was lining up for food.
I was grabbing like the Snoopy bun.
And yeah, Snoopy is the, oh yeah, I didn't even show you.
This is the craziest crossover of my life.
I did not realize that this, like, I thought it was so
funny.
Because it was like the craziest crossover of my life seeing
that in person.
um oh man i wish like obs lets me use a i hate having to
download it and then convert it as well uh but it uh there's
different properties at universal it's not just universal
stuff there's actually like different properties that they
own um that they'll not because sorry that not own but it's
like a collab and it's let me show you the picture of this
collab like i already said one of them and one of them was
snoopy i don't think you can guess the other two if you've
never been to universal japan before i don't think you can
guess what the other two are because it felt it's so random
it really is so random um let me see i can grab the phone
and let me see there's uh
it's bum bum
Elmo and Hello Kitty it's it's it's a wild crossover I know
but it's it's Snoopy Elmo and Hello Kitty I know it's it's I
know it's it's wild and this is the Avengers um but yes
these are what a trio I know the wildest combo collab i've
ever seen um but there's snoopy land there's elmo land and
there's halakutty land um that the trifecta halakitties oh
so also halakitties looking fabulous as fuck right now look
at this the halakitties she she's not wearing her she's like
damn slay girl like like slay name a more iconic trio the
holy trinity um but anyway Anyway, um, anyway, as I was
saying, sorry, I distracted there.
This is the entire stream of me getting distracted.
I, I like, the girl in front of me pulled up her credit
card, and it was a minion's credit card.
I, I was like, not like a sticker or anything.
It was an official, official credit card that has the
minions on it.
Like actual printed on.
to the card not a sticker but printed onto the card of the
minions and i was like where did she get that and where can
i have one too like i i was i was so surprised seeing that
like it was i was it was the minions it was really the
minions like she pulled out a minions credit yes she
pulled banks right now like I'm like I want to be like
worded like I wish I guess apparently it's very hard to get
a Japanese bank account by the way oh my gosh I read like a
story like I saw a video about it being like um if you have
to like move um if you have to move um out of Japan you have
to make sure you close your bank account before you are you
have to leave Japan because if you don't you lose that
account forever apparently because it's so um They're so
strict about like bank accounts in Japan that you yeah it's
like you can't you like if you don't have an address you
can't access your bank account
Or you make sure you have a new apartment but so that you
can um so that you don't lose your bank account forever But
still but still they do offer minions.
They do offer a minions credit card though.
So like I don't know the risk I'm willing to take like I'm
like but the pro side is that you get a minion's credit card
cons I feel like that's pretty much worth it cons I'm the
might be like the hardest like you know if you move you
might lose your account forever pros get a minion's credit
card
yeah small price to pay for the minions credit card guys I
feel like that's I don't know worth it I feel like it's such
a cool okay not gonna lie I feel like that's such a fucking
flex it's funny okay now like maybe flex is not the right
word but like I feel like like imagine you just pull out a
credit card like in front like don't worry guys I'll pay and
then you pull out the card and it's a fucking millions
credit card like I'll fucking use that all the time and I
was like with friends or some shit you know like guys don't
worry I'll pay for it that's
I got this
Oh my god Alice said something that Like reminded me that
pissed me up But not you and I it's just It gave me a
fucking memory when I Came home Um so like I thought I lost
My luggage guys I legitimately thought I lost my Luggage and
like Um that like the airline It just it was just gone Like,
it was just, I thought it was just gone, because I was like,
I waited for so long, but for some reason, like, my luggage,
and I had priority, that's the thing, like, there was no
reason, there was no reason for my luggage to take so long
to arrive, because I had priority, and, yeah, I was waiting.
Like my luggage was also waiting in line.
I mean, so I was so confused because I was like, where the
fuck is my, where the fuck is my luggage?
And so, and then I saw one that looked like mine and I
walked over to it, but I knew it wasn't mine because I had a
special luggage tag on it.
And like the other, this other person, it was literally like
the same, same one, the same one except for like, my luggage
tag wasn't on it and then it had stick like it had like some
tape around it and then I saw the name there was a tape name
tag and Haley you might not be watching this but fuck you
Haley because I was panicking and I thought I lost my luck
fuck you Haley I know it was you so anyway I waited anyway
the Haley luggage disappeared after a while when I was
watched because I had no luggage was coming out and um no
luggage was coming out so I was like shit like I saw the
loop several times the Haley luggage was gone but mine never
appeared so I was like oh no maybe I'm gonna I need to go up
to the counter and talk to someone because I think I lost my
luggage and I went to the other side of the of the baggage
carrier whatever the fuck this is called the It's a very big
conveyor belt.
So, like, I didn't see what was on the other side.
Walk to the other side because I had to go to the other side
to speak to someone.
And then I saw my fucking luggage on the floor just sitting
there.
So I know it's you, Haley.
I know it's you.
So whoever it was, and I assume it's Haley, they took my
luggage off the belt, left it on the floor, and didn't put
it back.
because they didn't grab the right one.
They didn't even put it back.
Why didn't she put it back on the conveyor?
I know it's you, Haley, because the Haley bag was gone.
The Haley luggage was gone.
But somehow they fucking didn't even bother to put my
luggage back on the fucking belt.
They just left it on the floor.
They actually just left.
person you're a fucking terrible person I hope it happens to
you too I so I literally waited I know it never ended me
waiting I waited there for 30 minutes trying to be like
where the fuck happened to my luggage like where did it go
like and I know it's air I know it's you like same brand the
same colors for our luggage who else would do that who
that's such a haily i hate your move um anyway i hope i had
i know that was like inside me that that hate was inside me
for a while i had to let it i could that was the most
exciting part that wanted to tell you guys on stream like i
i need to blast that ailey out of here i need to put her on
blast um um but yeah no i didn't get sick i finally i think
i finally did it i built up my immune system strong enough
where i actually did not get sick this time um i i came back
no cold went on food poisoning this is the healthiest i've
ever been on a vacation and like i i broke the streak i
finally broke the streak every time i traveled in the past
i've gotten sick but this is the first time in a long time
where i didn't i didn't get sick and i did it i i broke the
streak i'm like i i'm cured kyle thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you haley derogatory um peter Thank you
for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you All that trouble for a minion's credit card.
I don't know.
That sounds despicable to me Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
Another thing I'm so sad.
I didn't see the medoka sky tree thing.
I know a lot of people were posting about it flex bragging
about I I was going to see on the last day I had like Okay,
it was a risk because I did go there.
I went there and then like the ticket I got, the thing is I
was playing with time itself.
There was a potential of me missing my flight because I did
it.
I was so busy that the only time that was free to actually
see the Tokyo Sky Tremadoka.
I was so sad.
And then when I finally got to the airport and like checked
in and everything, I realized I had time.
I waited in the airport for two hours.
I was like, let's go gambling.
And then I chickened out.
And that's why you never, you never stop.
No, that's not the lesson here.
That's not the lesson here.
But that's why you always take the risk.
You always risk it for the biscuit.
It was worth the risk.
If I went in, if I wasn't a coward, I should have went all
in.
And I should have went all in.
I could have made it to my flight Because I was so worried I
thought it was like you have to check in one hour before
your flight But I thought It was one hour before boarding
time But it's actually one hour before departure time So I
got confused with boarding time and departure time Because I
thought it was like I thought it has to be one hour before
boarding time And I was like oh I'm not gonna make it And
then I realized when I got there And I checked in and
everything.
And I looked at, and I googled.
One hour before, and I googled.
It was like one hour before departure time.
I was like, I could have made it.
I could have went and saw Madoka.
I, oh my, I was so sad.
I actually was like, oh my gosh, I went in all in.
I shouldn't have been a fucking coward.
I, no.
The thing was, the scariest part was that there was
apparently traffic at that time.
And it said it would take one hour to get to the airport.
So I was just like, oh no.
left it was just 30 minutes it was just like 20 to 30
minutes and i was like i i should have went all in i i could
have gambled i should have i that was the riskiest part i
was like i checked google maps one time it said one hour and
then when i finally got a cab to the airport it was 20 to 30
minutes and i was like oh my god i could have i could have
went all in i i am so scared of missing my plate i was like
oh no what if i missed the flight i i was so sad because
like the collaboration ends like in one or two weeks too so
i didn't get to see it that's like one of the one thing one
of the things i missed the like one things i regret the most
was i didn't get to see the madoka collab uh for Tokyo
Skytree because I wanted to go to the cafe too I wanted to
go to the cafe uh yeah I'm missing a fight with really suck
ass but I missed but it's madoka magica guys it was madoka
magica guys I like I was such a hardcore fan I like
literally watched the movies and theater I owned so much
merch of madoka stuff She's my minion.
She's my minion.
Alright, also here's a picture.
Here's a special picture for you guys.
The Yoshi eating ass.
Don't worry, this picture is so worth it.
I took this picture and I sent it to like three of my
friends.
I was like, look at this Yoshi eating ass.
look at him nibbling sorry not eating he's nibbling oh shit
who rated i'm sorry i don't who rated
look at this like this was the okay look the Yoshi ride was
worth it for just this picture Like every The fucking two
minute ride Was worth it only for this picture I took Other
than that It was not worth it It was It was not worth it
This was the one part This is the one part where I was like
You know what maybe Maybe this ride Was a pretty good ride
why does he look like that i don't know but but it was a fun
oh yeah here's i bought this merch i had i had to buy okay
so um what also what i found is the stuff i found out was
popular uh the stuff that's popular in japan i would never
expect them expected to be popular but for who don't know um
thoughts on yoshi being voiced by donald glover in the
upcoming mario movie i think that's pretty neat i think
donald glover is a very good voice actor because he he can
do tracy morgan did you guys know that if you guys ever
heard this song where with our mitzvah so he's scary boys
becoming wolves wolves becoming men or is it boys becoming
men men becoming wolves That was actually sang by Childish
Gambino slash Donna Glover.
That was not sang by Tracy Morgan.
He is very good at voice acting.
People just forgot about that.
He's very talented in a lot.
Yeah, that was him.
He actually, because like, Tracy didn't want to sing it, so
then he sang it himself.
He's a very good writer, singer, and actor.
It's actually, he's like, that man is fucking talented.
He has everything.
What does he not have?
Like, never heard of him you might know him from childish
Gambino he does a lot of writing and everything I'm trying
to find I'm gonna need because it's so stupid I have to come
reconvert the images because I want to show you guys
something uh where is oh there you go this and the food so
all right nice thing where some of you guys might not know
oh yeah he's in community by the way he's basically Troy
from community Troy and I've been in the morning um But
here's a little fun fact.
In Japan, Jaws is very popular, too.
For those who don't know, they also have a very...
They have a popular fandom of Jaws in Japan.
There's a lot of Jaws merch.
A lot of people are taking pictures with Jaws.
That's not too much on the Jaws booth.
Where I didn't have to line up.
that really wanted and I will show you guys this merch and
you will understand why I had to buy it
I had to buy it you know when you see it you'd understand
why I must make this purchase so
So, I mean, I mean, obviously man sharp, but then the other
one, I was like, oh my god,
so I was like, oh my god, so I was like, oh my god, in
public, yeah, yeah, so, damn, that's Shark's a fucking
freak.
I was just like, um, what is, okay, it's crazy.
I was like, is he?
I was like, damn, that shark is freaky.
And in public too.
And it's a freaky shark.
I had to, I had to grab the, the tied up shark and also the
man's shark.
Cause I was like, I, I did not Google.
Um, so.
I now own two very freaky sharks.
Um, and was it worth it?
But yeah, it's, I'm gonna, and I will, I'm gonna put, I'm
putting one of them on my bag.
I don't know which one yet.
It's very hard.
It's very hard to decide which freaky shark I want on my
bag.
Uh, half man, half shark.
Yeah.
Also, like, the merch there is actually crazy.
There's, like, there are these hats, these, like, hats where
you can press it and then, like, stuff would move on it.
So, like, the Nintendo one was, I bought this fish one.
I wish I could show you guys, but then I don't want to dox
myself.
Let me see if I can find a video of it.
I bought, I bought, I bought the fish one because I thought
it was the silliest one.
Fish hat, Nintendo world.
All right, here, oh, I don't want this one.
It's the cheap, cheap one.
Because I thought it was the funniest one.
This is what it looks like.
So I'm not doxing myself, but this is the hat I own now.
I wore it back from Osaka in the bullet train back to Tokyo.
Back home.
And everyone was like, I had no shame.
I was like, I spent X how much, I don't know how much it
was.
I was just like that shit was that's a good hat that that's
a fucking good hat um so when you press it um the flippers
move and everything they have a boo version yeah the cheap
cheap yeah they were jealous of course I knew they were all
so jealous um of my hat um so there was a cheap cheap one
there was a yoshi one where when you press it the tongue
comes out there was a boo one where he um you press it he uh
basically like um revealed like he moves his hand so that
he's like you know he's not peekabooing like you know it's
the peekaboo basically you press it he's like let's go of
his hands and stuff um but there was i think i don't
remember what the fourth one was but those were the three i
remember by the way it was so cute everyone that was like
dressing up or wearing of like of their favorite character
in universal it's so cute the headbands the headbands and
the hats and everything everyone was dressing up i saw like
i saw like some kid wearing like a bowser backpack where it
looked like he had was basically bowser and stuff it was
really cute um yeah the headbands there was one where it
looks like yoshi was on your head because it blends so well
with black hair yoshi nintendo world i was like oh my god
everyone was like there was a minion group and everything
there was a group of minions where like everyone was wearing
the minion PJs I saw like oh my god I haven't talked in a
long time I have to like build up my build up my like
talking like meter um it's like you don't it's like you
don't understand I I wish I could stop talking about the
minions but they were everywhere
And you don't understand.
They were everywhere.
I can't stop talking about them.
And I just see them everywhere.
All right, let me see.
Oh, yeah.
And then I'll show you guys the monster hunter food dish I
got.
But before I show you guys, let me make sure that nothing is
showing.
I didn't like pre-check these photos by the way.
I'm doing it live.
Like, do it live.
I shirt though, but I couldn't be bothered.
I'm, I came home, I came back home, slept for 14 hours,
played Overwatch, went back to bed, woke up, uploaded my
waiting room, played an extra hour
could pre- I don't know where I could pre-check my photos
guys my schedule was so packed guys I don't know at what
exact time I could have pre-checked my photos guys I it was
just so packed when could I have the opportunity to do that
no time see I told you there was just time how could i i was
just so busy oh all right here we go help me budget my time
my managers cry play less overwatch i don't think you're
taking this seriously i here it is it's so cute guys oh my
god it's literally like a monster it's like like i said it's
literally a monster hunter like the uh like a food you can
get from the monster hunter universe it's so good it was so
good it was it was really it was like i said it's the last
day of the collab bro i don't even know how much i think it
was all in yen i i can i converting it is too much for my
small brain uh i love the potion like the green potion i
don't even know what flavor that was it was good though
everything But yeah, it was last day.
I'm glad I got it on the last day.
I don't need to...
Wait, I need to go reheat my pizza.
I'll be right...
Actually, I haven't...
Yeah, I'm gonna go reheat my pizza.
I'll be right back, guys.
I don't get food.
I'm hungry.
I go grab food, guys.
BRB.
I'm back.
I got...
I didn't reheat pizza.
I reheated my carbonara udon.
There's a new place.
There's a new restaurant.
Well, I don't know.
Maybe it's an old restaurant.
They just had they just had Uber Eats for it, but it's so
good.
Carbonara udon is so fucking good.
Zechra, 12, Howard, aka Neppers, aka WB, Saver, Papa, Medi,
Solid.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
It's delicious.
All right.
Let me take a bite real quick before I start yapping again.
I really miss talking to you guys.
wish i did um i i wish i did do like a midstream i'm sorry
uh a stream in the middle of my vacation but like no time
every every day there's some stuff going on
but also like i'm glad to be back i really miss streaming
for you guys and just yapping about stupid shit with all you
guys there's so much stuff going on
i don't it's good to be back all right i'm Looking through
my, oh my god.
I bought, oh my god, I saw my Nendroy.
I saw my Nendroy at Akihabara.
I took a picture of it.
I was like, oh my god, it's me.
I'm not going to show it because I can't be bothered to
like, can't be bothered to do the conversion right now.
But I saw it at Akihabara.
If you're ever in Japan, you need my Nendroy.
You can get it there right now.
It's right there.
It's at...
It's at your, it's at the Ami Ami store.
I think that, I think it's the, yeah, it's at the Ami Ami
store.
Yeah, it's right there.
All right, let me see.
God, I miss revolving sushi.
I went there, I went to Sashiro and Kura.
Um, oh my God, I found it.
All right, instead of, I'm just gonna snip this.
So, if you're going to Mintz Collab Cafe and you're like,
where is it?
um right across the street is this fucking scary ass olaf
statue apparently that just that's been there for years from
what she told me she said this this scary ass olaf statue
has been living across the street for years so you're
confused and you're like where is the collab cafe just look
If you see this There's nobody It's a statue by the way
There's no man inside it I was like This looks like a Chilla
arts game I literally told her That shit's a Chilla arts
game right there Like I feel like that's something to see
Like one of the NPCs in that game Like It's like Apparently,
it's just the mannequin inside.
Push it back.
That's what it is.
But.
It.
It's wearing some fishnets, by the way.
You can't see it.
Yeah, let me.
I think the worst part is I was wearing fishnets.
I was like, why?
Yeah, let me see, I can enhance.
You can tell that.
He's wearing ripped fishnets, too.
I don't know if that makes it better or worse.
I don't know.
Oh, my God, it does.
Why is it ripped?
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
Oh, yeah, okay.
uh there's another thing i wanted to tell you guys i went to
the muscle bar uh with feisty and emily we got really cute
we got a really cute girl muscle lady um for eyes so for
those who don't know the muscle bar it's an infamous bar
like you know those bean bars and everything um none of us
went me feisty emily and andy um none of us have ever been
there and i was like you know what my treat it's every time
i always want to go there like something happens i could
never go to the muscle bar i was like today is the day today
is that day i'm gonna go to the muscle bar and let me so
i'll show you guys the group photo they're all very muscular
i think we had the best muscle girl i'm pretty sure so um so
basically is a theme bar where they're i was i did not know
what i expected because i don't know like this you can get
people slapping and everything um so basically we have like
they give like a regular performance it's like one hour it's
i felt like a speed run i didn't realize like the one hour
goes by super fast by the way i will warn you guys if you
ever go to muscle bar um it goes by super fast
so you're not you're not expect it to go by that fast i'll
show you guys the let's see the picture i tweeted out with
everybody so we got the cutest girl i know that for sure so
this is the muscle bar so the muscle girls i also have the
jacket i bought the i bought the jacket you see me right
held up in the sky and we had the cutest muscle girl the one
in the glasses the one below feisty um below feisty at the
not that the one below feisty that was our muscle girl she
was so cute she was so tiny let me show you a funny video
that um they took so we basically we get extra orders yeah
the one in the beanie so let's see emily sent me the other
videos sonia get it so basically oh yeah i don't know if i
can show this one because
okay okay i'm gonna all right this is me play if this gets
restricted if this gets rt restricted
okay so there was one option what's called the muscle
sandwich and It was only reserved for ladies only so we're
like why is it ladies only and then Emily got it She's doing
content and so she's doing vlog and everything.
I'm so just like everything for content Oh my god.
It's so loud.
I That was so loud.
Okay There we go.
There we go.
Let me I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Here we go
Only the ladies can get that option.
And we get to pick our muscle, ladies.
We get to pick.
Oh, and then, all right, here's them getting slapped.
Let me see if I can.
Oh, I think I'm watching this.
And then here's them getting slapped.
This one with the...
left side was the more buff one
I didn't pick anything I didn't I was like you guys go do
your thing I was like we saw like a group of guys okay so
there was one option in the menu where it was like inside
we're thinking was a super chat thank you thank you That
should have been to me.
So it's called the Muscle Girls, Muscle Girls Bar.
And we saw a group of, like there was a group of guys in
front of us.
And they, two of them picked, there's an option in the menu
where you get all the girls at the muscle bar to slap you or
kick you in the butt.
So this guy, this buff-ass dude, big-ass buff dude.
was like, I want that option where all the ladies slapped
me.
And then by the time it ended, he got a nose bleed.
He got slapped so fucking hard that he had to go to the
bathroom because his nose was bleeding.
I was like, damn.
I was just like, holy shit.
Oh my, cool boy.
Bro, some of the girls did not, like, went hard.
We watched them get slapped so fucking hard.
They went hard hard.
Like, he was like, no, no, I'm pretty sure.
Pretty sure it was from the slap.
He was, he got fucked, demolished.
And he drove to the restaurant.
Did it order?
No, I got, like, the, I paid for everybody, guys, except for
the extra stuff.
I was like, if you guys want the extra stuff, the slaps,
because, like, that is, like, on top of it, for like our all
general tickets to get in and watch the more i'll show you
guys the show is wild the show is crazy but um and then but
they want to get slapped or carried or piggyback rides but
okay here watch this this
is andy this is andy our staff the capcom staff by the way
he's he looks so happy he looked yay yeah he's doing easy i
cried in the squad he was so happy
he's living the life like oh my god wait i have a better
video of it let me see i can find it let me say i could find
the video okay was it oh there it is okay Oh, wait, here,
let me show you guys.
Okay, I requested a video, too.
Wait, I did request two...
I did request two photos and a videos.
I'll show you guys the videos.
Thank God is up.
He's so, she's so small.
She is so small.
Our muscle girl was so cute and small.
I was like, what are you going to do?
I was like, yeah!
And then, and then here, here were the photos.
That's fluffy.
I'm winning.
That's for sure.
Let me.
I'm winning.
winning that's
a cure in toky wins again what i got i got that i got that i
got that
so happy for you all right wait what is it oh wait i got
this too i got this as well i forgot i got sorry i forgot i
also got the piggybacker Look at me go
Yeah I'm wearing it
Yeah!
Woo!
I got my piggybacker
upbees I got my upbees I think She's so cute Oh my gosh,
she's like She's so cute, wait, I got no Wait, where's
the...
Um...
Oh my god, there's Feisty.
Look at Feisty here.
This is funny.
I'm back and...
Look at this, she's so tiny.
This shows how tiny she is.
Look at this.
Look at this, she has to stand up here.
And then...
Oh yeah!
Look at this, look at this.
Look how tiny she is.
Oh my god!
She's so small!
Look at that!
Holy shit!
No, she- no, it's crazy.
You don't notice like how fucking buff she is until like,
until she starts flexing.
I was so surprised.
I was not expecting how fucking buff she was until she
started flexing.
It was- it was crazy like um wait let's see oh my god wait
let me show you this video of emily i'm so happy for you
don't keep positively glad that you got to be real this is
why i wasn't streaming guys this is you know when i said i
was enjoying my vacation i was i was enjoying my
is trying to enjoy my big okay this might be okay it's the
wrong angle but you'll make sense okay it's still the wrong
angle there we go look at this look how tiny she is oh my
god look at this she's like will it work look at this oh my
god Holy fuck.
She's so strong.
She is actually...
She is so strong.
We're like, holy fuck.
I know.
Okay, I need to show you guys this video.
I need to make sure this video is okay, though.
Alright.
I gotta make sure not...
Like I said, I didn't check anything.
Alright, so...
This is part of the regular performance.
This goes hard.
I need you guys to watch this.
This goes fucking hard.
Let me download this real quick.
I know I said it and I need to download it.
All right.
For not ditching us, for not ditching us, I know it must
have been a very hard, I had to thought very long and hard
about.
Whether or not I'll ever come back after that day.
Solid Snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, here, look at this.
Oh, wait.
All right, let me rotate this real quick.
Uh, whoops.
That's not right.
There we go.
All right.
This is, this goes wild.
Disclaimer.
fucking wild this was like part of the performance not not
that part not that that one was for free that one was for
free like totally shit like Holy fuck!
Yeah, so...
I'm ready to take you...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Like, you saw those fucking biceps though?
I am such cute bro okay no no look at when she was like when
she was like when she was like yeah like you look at her
arms you're like oh she's our muscle girl she's really cute
though but like and then whoa
yet the guns came out bam like look at that that was fucking
wild she's so cute I know I keep saying but she was so
fucking cute the sleeper build wait I have another video let
me see let me check this video
let me check this other video
okay okay okay let me show you this video all right this is
from why did you choose us the hell solid thank you in the
super chat thank you that i'm showing you the light so you
will also i'm showing you the light guys i came back just so
to spread the word
to spread to spread the gospel like
i was like if every i have to preach the word of god i'm the
prophet amen like hey here you go i have to show you guys
this this one's crazy right here though we need i need to
see like right here You see, those are muscle dollars, by
the way.
Oh,
no!
I got front row seats, baby.
Amen.
a fucking man no that's the best a fucking not shown in this
video because I didn't realize she was gonna do that in the
middle of that in the middle of that show she started doing
pull-ups because there's a pull-up bar above her and then
the really buff one just started doing pull-ups and I was
like oh my god what the fuck and it was like whoa like one
two three and i was like jesus christ
anyway that was the muscle girl bar it was truly it's an
experience it i do want to mention lemon sours are so
popular in japan i have no everyone kept getting lemon sours
like all like every time we go it was just lemon sours every
time i i don't know understand i've never but lemon sours
until this trip to Japan.
It's just, it's a type of alcoholic drink.
And it's lemon.
It's a sour lemon with alcohol.
I never had it before.
But it's so popular.
It's so popular here.
I just wanted to let you guys know that.
Have a chance.
Oh yeah, there's pole dancing.
Most forgot.
I watched pool dancing, too.
Let's see.
Oh, it's insane.
I don't know if I could show this on video.
I don't know if I could show the pool dancing.
I don't know if that's, like, too risky for YouTube.
But there was also pool dancing, and I don't know if I could
show it.
Yeah.
And it was...
it was intense it was that i feel like that's a little too
risky but it was intense it was like it was like like skill
po dancing where they were literally like vertical and
everything and they were like vertical and everything and it
was oh my god it was crazy hey sir thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you it should have been me not her look
at this tower you can look it up guys there's lots of videos
i love it um um save it for okay i'll show it on the members
if i if a members bot gets re oh my god we have to show you
guys this um so we went to care karaoke um uh right at the
end we went to karaoke um to uh at round one at the very end
and I swear to God could not make this up I I have to tell
you guys about this because it was like it was so wild I
didn't think this would happen to me so we ordered our theme
you know like there's like theme drinks and everything where
um yeah join if you want to see the members join members if
you want to see pole dancing if you want to see the pole
dancing video I took um But I was like, I saw a Hitalia
collab.
I saw a Hitalia collab.
And I was like, you know what?
Let me grab this Hitalia drink.
Because you get like a little coaster.
You get a little coaster.
And I didn't really care much.
I haven't, like it was one of the first cringe fandom I've
ever joined.
And I was just like, oh my God, I'll grab the Hitalia one.
Like that drink looks cool.
And I could grab like a souvenir from this karaoke.
It's wild.
I actually freaked out.
But I opened the pack and I got Prussia.
I actually started screaming.
I was like, it was like back and back.
I was like, I was transported back in those days.
Because it was like one out of 20 chances to get this guy.
This was my favorite character, by the way.
Prussia was my favorite character in the Talia.
Like I was so obsessed with him.
And I was just like, I was literally screaming.
What are the odds?
Oh, I can see everybody.
It's like, oh my, what are the odds?
It's like I've never left.
Because I didn't even realize he was in the pool.
I just saw America.
I got the America drink.
And I was like, oh my God.
It was meant to be.
Like, you could never truly leave Italian.
It was truly meant to be.
But we didn't carry it to sign.
fucking sign.
I'm relapsing.
But yeah, anyway, I was freaking out because I was like, oh
my God.
It's pressure.
Oh my God.
I really wanted to talk about, I really wanted to show you
guys that because I was fucking freaking out.
Anyway, I found the Capcom store.
I know I'm like, there's no time frame with all the stories.
Oh my God, before I tell you guys this, this is not creepy
this okay this might be a little creepy but as i was walking
back to my hotel um i saw an old man uh old man i asked
permission by the way so like he knows i took the photos oh
that's i know that sounds so creepy that's not that creepy i
swear to god it's i walking a pair of weiner dogs and I was
freaking out because I was like, Oh my God, he has a pair of
weeder dogs and they were so cute.
So I took a picture and I went up to him and I was like, I
have, can I pet him?
Because I was just like, you know, I was missing dad.
And then, and I did take a picture of random old man.
I was just like, hello weeder dog.
I was just like, and okay.
So I was like telling him, I have a weeder dog.
He's like, you have dogs in and I was like yes um so it's
not creepy but basically I was walking down the street
trying to walk to my hotel and then I took up and I was like
oh my god weiner dogs and I was like and I you know I
thought he and then and then I was like I walked up to him
and I was like can I take photos and then look how cute
they're so cute it's so creepy i asked for mission after
like i took a photo it said okay and he's like yes um you're
stalking him i won't
but look at them i was like i and i was getting like dog
sick i was just like i'm miss dad um and
um um you asked permission after i just like i wouldn't have
shown the photo if i didn't ask permission guys and and it
was they were so cute and i like pet him and everything and
he had it like you saw the stroller he had that was for the
dogs he had a little doggy stroller for them if They get
tired.
I was like, bro, this old man is a weener dog enthusiast.
He actually He actually he had like a little dog stroller
for it when they get tired.
I was like, oh my god If he get if dad gets tired, I guess
like because he can't just pick two dogs up, you know, if
they Um, bro, I'll just pick up dad if he gets tired.
I don't need a stroller for that.
But like there's them so of course he's gonna have a
stroller all right let me all right let me look through my
my log i kept a little log book of everything that happened
so i could talk about my day
um wow must be nice those weiner dogs are living life while
he has to use his two feet
now show the picture of dad when he gets back I have a
picture of him pooping from the dog city.
You guys want to see that?
He gives eye contact too.
If you guys want to see that.
Let me see.
Where's the photo?
He gives eye contact too.
Do you guys want to see that?
No.
Why is it always pooping?
When I was there, I walked into a dog stroller store.
It was set up like an Apple store for dogs, right?
Japan loves their tiny dogs.
Don't make them walk.
Don't make them wait in line.
That's so evil.
Bro, give that dude privacy.
I didn't take the phone of my dog sitter token.
I don't know why they sent me a photo.
I'm shitting.
Don't look at me.
I didn't fucking ask for it.
I was just an unwilling participant just like you guys
And you're spreading it around not yet Okay, I did send it
to some one guy
That's it I only sent it to one person
I was like, look at this photo of my dog sitter sent me.
I'm like, what the hell, Toki?
They're like, why did you?
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot to tell this story.
But when I was going on the ride, thinking, when I was doing
my transfer um to tokyo um for my flight i i the one thing
you guys might notice was missing from my photos if you guys
are following my twitter there was one set of photos like
one foot set of photos i didn't take that i've like finally
broke the streak of because i always take those types of
photos whenever i'm traveling we're plane photos i didn't
take any plane photos with like my plushies or anything,
which I've always done in my previous trips where there was
acrylic stab.
The reason why is that both on both my flights, I saw VTuber
fans and you might be like, oh, maybe there's just like JP.
No, I saw people with hollow EN and mint merch on their
bags.
So I was like, panic.
So I I was like don't be suspicious don't don't be
suspicious and not just mint merch but they were from like I
saw like merch of like from the jazz concert too so like it
was just one person it was several people so I was just like
oh fuck like yeah yeah just like act natural so I I didn't
pull out any of my VTuber stuff because I was like, that was
so scary because I was just like, holy fuck, I gotta, I
gotta make sure and I don't look like I'm fucking traveling
to Japan for VTuber stuff.
I was fine too because so that's why there were no photos.
There were no photos because like, you see, it would have
been easier if my plushie was already like distributed it
might have been easier but i'm the only one that owns the
god the own owns the dokey plushies right now i'm literally
the only one that owns the dokey plushies so i couldn't be
like you know there was the acrylics yeah the one of a god
merch at the moment because like you know if the plush was
already distributed out or shipped out made like you know
made up to you guys then then it'll be fine because you know
at least like I could just be like a Dragoon I could just be
like you guys you know just blend in the blend in the crowd
but not no like the not Doki Prime but the regular Doki
plushie the one that's being sold right now yeah it would
just been like oh it's a Doki Brits fan just a Dragoon but
then I owned the only plushie right now in existence that so
so I couldn't I couldn't fucking I couldn't fucking do it
and I was surprised because it was after it was after Hollow
Fest too and like assume it was for the I assume it was also
for the mint cafe but then obviously the mint cafe was going
on during Hollow Fest so I was I don't know So I was just
like, why are you flying out right after the event?
Like, I know when we're leaving, when I was leaving, it was
like, it makes more sense when you're leaving.
But when I was flying there, I was a bit confused.
So I didn't pull out the plushie during like those moments.
That's why I didn't, that's why I didn't like, um, I, I, I
didn't like pull, Pull it out and took those photos.
That was like one time, the scariest time to ever take those
photos.
Like, I didn't do it.
Pika, they give us super chat.
Thank you.
Doki said, let me know.
Dad gives you any shit and they took it literally.
Pika, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So I was just like, well, not taking that out.
All right.
Let's see you.
What was it?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, let me show you guys pictures of, oh, my God, the
whole thing was about Capcom Cup.
I talked about everything but Capcom Cup.
Other than the fun times, I can't even make it.
Okay, so it was very fun.
It was, honestly, I had a lot of fun at Capcom Cup.
Like I said, at first I thought I was just going to go for
like two days.
Like, because it was like a four to five day event.
And I didn't think I was going to go for every.
day but I went every day like I didn't watch every single
match but I did I went every day because it was so cool like
it was so fucking hype let me there was one thing that I was
I loved and like I don't know if it was like no I don't
think it was noticeable during like um broadcast because
like you guys don't really get to see the audience but every
time let me see if I can find the video
the match let me say i couldn't find it it's so cool it's
basically they like the entire audience do does like this
chance and everything up here they give a super chat they
can thank i had so much fun in japan um i i said it before
but this was my most fun trip so far in japan i've been to
japan so many times um but this is the most social i've ever
been and also the most fun i've ever because i like i met a
lot of people i interacted a lot of people i became friends
with a lot of new people and i did a lot of things i did a
lot of things i wasn't as paranoid as i was in the past um i
still am paranoid i did like um when i went there i gave my
ground rules i was like please no photos no photos uh uh if
you do group photos like just like especially with social
media or anything you do group photos please use my plushies
um no irl streaming if i'm there and And then, because like,
Emily was doing RL streaming, but she made sure to not do it
during the times when, um, when I was there.
So I had laid some ground rules before I came, and I was
just like, I can't do this, I can't do that.
So I hope you guys can accommodate.
And they did, they accommodated everything.
And, um, and, um, I told them like, oh, if we're taking
photos, we're photos, just please just, you know, use this
plus sheet to do the photos.
That's why I like, uh, uh, like when you see it, it was just
all like the photos.
uh from the with the plushies and everything all right let
me see if i can find the video it's so cool i'm gonna try to
see it
all right and i'm trying to find the cool video right now
like no you guys don't understand it's so sick let's see oh
it's this one here you go oh wait there has to be a better
video i'm sorry i'm like you don't understand it's actually
so when I find it.
It's so sick.
Maybe it's this.
Oh, here we go.
I found it.
So, I don't think you guys see this.
If you guys follow, if you guys follow like FGC or stuff
like that, this wasn't really, I don't, or like watch the
Capcom Cup.
So, basically, let me get the video.
There's like a character intro where they, all come in and
stuff and they um the entire audience would like react to
the intro and it was so cool it was so cool watching it i'll
double check if everything is okay like i said i didn't
pre-check anything i just went and be like all right here
you go uh this it's so sick i mean you must be like what's
so sick about this so you see the intro it was basically
By the way on the last two days a pair of the yet the
chance.
Yeah on the last two days It was fully sold out from what
we're told So it was like this Yeah, boom boom boom boom
boom yeah, so they would do that I thought it was so cool I
thought I was so sick.
I love that Yeah, yeah
Yeah, and then they would, like, light up the stadium and
everything.
And they would do that for, they would do that.
Yeah, it was so high.
And they would do that for, like, every intro, like, every
time they start the match.
And I didn't know that.
And it was so cool to see.
It was just so high.
Sorry, I was blowing my nose.
And because it's the 21st, right?
The pay-per-view deadline thing.
So now I can show clips on the 21st, yeah.
I gotta be sure.
It is the 21st, right?
Um.
Anyone that knows the rules.
Is it the 21st where you can start posting clips, guys?
Was it?
Yes?
Okay.
Luckily, it's the 21st today.
So I timed it perfectly.
All right.
Here you go.
Look.
Don't worry, guys.
I got you.
I got.
Guys, don't worry, guys.
Now that I'm legally allowed to post this clip, let's show
this clip.
I can show you guys this.
This clip, guys.
It's pretty sick.
It was...
It's the last match.
It's literally the last round.
We watch.
It's the last round.
Whoa!
Yeah, it's literally the last round.
That is so cool.
The audience is so cool.
The grand final!
This is a watch party now.
Whoa, ending the finals?
Who could have guessed?
Yo, the crowd lighting is crazy.
I love it.
It was such a sick arena.
And then you could see it.
You can see it.
Look at him.
He's so happy.
Woo!
Bum, no, no, no, no, no.
Look at him, go.
It was so hype
Yeah, okay, that's crazy I found out Okay, for those who
don't know The guy that won He was a Fortnite player Then he
was a Valorant player And then a year ago He swapped to
fighting games Apparently And then this is his first big
tournament is that crazy it's crazy this man was a fortnite
slash valorant player he was like you know what i'm gonna be
a fighting game player now and literally within a year a
year he fucking won capcom i was like that's insane yeah
yeah this is like literally his first was it this is first
big tournament yeah this first i think is i don't know but
is this his first time this first time qualifying Capcom
Cup, I thought that was wild.
That was just some person was just born to be an esport
gamer.
Like, someone get fact-checked me, but this might be his
first time in Capcom Cup, and he literally just won it all.
I thought it was insane.
That's just insane.
Yeah, his first time in Capcom Cup, his first big tournament
in just one year.
Oh, he's young.
He's supposed to be young as hell.
He was literally a Fortnite and Valorant pro gamer.
And it's like, you know what?
I think I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go into FGC now.
Yeah.
Yeah, and first prize was a million dollars.
That's crazy.
This guy's set for life.
Actually set for.
life yeah and here's a photo i took i was just like look at
him he won oh my god he did it it was here yeah now he's a
millionaire after that set for life basically apparently
there was a curse or some shit where like everyone who wins
capcom cup basically retires but people were like there's no
way he's gonna retire he just started his career like he's
gonna break it the streak right Here you go.
I took this photo.
I was just like, hello, Doki here.
That was cool.
But yeah.
I made a million US dollars and then convert it to yen,
chat.
Convert that to yen.
Like, so he's like, well, like, you can't really buy.
Guys, a million US dollars converted to yen.
You can buy anything in Japan.
You know?
Yeah, it's a million us jesus yeah
yeah 100 million yen all right there's another thing i
wanted to show you guys oh yeah also the jury bike was here
but then like i feel like apparently the jury bike travels
around a lot because it goes to lots of evos and everything
but it's still sick um fg tournaments are so much fun i went
to my co-attorney a gambling ring formed around it everyone
started betting on their friends it was yay gambling uh l
tigra thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh
he's 21 bro that's damn that's crazy he's 21 holy shit okay
let me show you guys the jury bike we also saw the jury bike
too i mean the jury bike is always sick though check the
photo jury bike has a lot of reflections but it's okay it
doesn't have the the scary type of reflection here's me
riding the jury bike look at this
guys i'm right guys i'm riding the jury bike guys it looks
sick
Oh, let me go.
I'm riding the bike, guys.
Broom, broom.
Let me get her go.
Got a little booster seat and everything.
I'm there.
No helmet.
How do you steer with my mind?
I steer with my mind, guys.
I'm that good.
let me see if i have anything else to show any other videos
from capcon cup it comes with autopilot
all right this one is pretty cool i'll show you guys this
video these are like intros basically the intro walk-ins he
said i can grab it real quick all right these are loud
though so i need to look at the videos
with this oh here it is I think it's this oh it's on the
other side again they're loud though this video is loud as
hell all
right I think it's sick the walk-ins
And then they come from here.
And so I know.
And this is like day one, by the way.
This was day one.
Apparently qualified.
You know, people don't.
People want to watch the finals.
And then they walk around this area.
I was like.
Oh, that's sick.
That's pretty sick.
I thought it was super hype and everything.
Yeah.
And you're like.
It's this guy.
Whoa.
It's pretty hype though.
All right, let me look through.
All right, now it's food time.
Are you guys ready to look at food?
We ate so much stuff.
Holy fuck.
I, all right, I'm trying to see where I can, where I can
show you guys.
I ate a, we ate so much stuff.
A lot of, and like the good shit was paid off by Capcom too.
So thank you, Capcom.
Oh wait, before that, before that, I did show this on
Twitter, but I'll show it again here.
But I got an autograph from the Street Fighter director
himself.
Whoa!
Let me show you guys.
It wasn't just an autograph, though, by Nakayama-san.
Oh my god, that's crazy.
I'll tell the story again for those who don't follow me on
Twitter.
But, okay, this shit is sick, though.
Whoops, Nakayama-san is cutting in half.
all right for those who don't know this guy he's literally
the street fighter director mr nakayama son um and i know
it's russ and i was just like i just wanted an autograph you
know because you know i i'm not gonna ask him for art like i
just wanted an autograph like um uh like uh uh like uh like
kenny and um and And so I asked Andy, our Capcom staff, if
he could go find Nakayama-san and have him, you know, give
me an autograph.
And then I was like, why is it taking so long?
I was just like, I thought he's just writing his name.
And then the staff texted me back and was like, he wants to
hand deliver this to you.
And I was like, huh?
you know i was like what do you mean hand deliberate like
what it's like he did something of he he did more than just
an autograph and then he literally showed up in like
original art like oh my god it's it's crazy i was just like
holy like he actually drew me a custom hondo honda artwork
just for me like none of my teammates got it because um um
um because like didn't ask for an autograph because like
yeah i always take my shot i always want to collect these
things because i thought you know you know it's cool like
i'm meeting all these amazing people i want to have like
some memorabilia for meeting them so i always ask for
autographs from like people i meet just because i feel like
you know it's such an amazing experience i don't know when
i'll ever meet these people again i don't know when i'll
meet kenny again if i will if i like if i if we ever cross
paths again i don't know if i'll meet nakayama san again i
don't know so i asked for an autograph because i don't know
when it'll ever happen like if i'll meet them like a little
souvenir from meeting them so i always ask these people for
autographs it's like you know always shoot your shot better
but you know always take the opportunity the worst they can
say is no and i fucking gave me a custom autograph like
literally a one-of-a-kind honda artwork um so it was it's
crazy it was crazy i mean i have a close-up of this let me
find it real quick it was it was insane i never i literally
never expected and it looks amazing I was so scared by the
way it was also like the worst time to give me anything to
hold on to because that was the day that we were gonna see
punch the monkey so well all of this was happening while I
was fucking at the zoo I was holding on to the fucking
autograph while trying to wait for punch the monkey because
I Also, I was so scared.
I was so scared I was going to damage the autograph because
I was trying to fucking terrible timing, by the way.
I couldn't like, like, now I understand it.
So I was just like, freaking paranoid as shit that was going
to damage the autograph because I had nowhere to put it.
There were no lockers.
No way to put it.
I have to hold it wherever I go.
And somehow this is, it is Punch's fault.
Like, so it was terrible.
timing all around um because that was the one day I had we
were going to go to the zoo to see punch the fucking monkey
um all right let me see I could find I took a like a solo
photo the autograph so that I could show you guys the beauty
of it in the full picture maybe I'll show you guys the stuff
I bought the next day because I oh my god how I've been
streaming for oh my I've been You guys still, we've been all
deprived of yaps.
It does not feel like four hours.
Holy fuck.
I'm having a great time, though.
I hope you guys are having a great time.
All right, let's see.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Trying to find...
Oh, there you go.
Oh, my God.
I just realized...
I just realized Okay Now that I can see it close up Some of
you guys pointed it out I was like surely that doesn't say
that I just realized Something a little typo Some of you
guys might have already seen the typo I didn't even notice
it So someone kept saying it was like Why does this say
that?
I was like Surely it doesn't say that
it's so you know what it's like a pokemon misprint guys guys
it's like the pokemon misprint you know it makes it even
more valuable the more it makes it's better exactly it's
better this way it raises the value oh whoops it's upside
down okay there might be a slight typo
It makes it more unique.
But here it is.
Here it is in all its glory.
It's still pretty cool.
I...
Oh, now I see it.
And all I got for Toki Bread?
now yeah exactly now the value has tripled after that maybe
i i should change my name to dokey bridge just to be safe
just to be you know how you're like i i like people will
just change your name to match it just to be like you know
it works now i'm dokey bridge guys thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you it was on purpose so that people
saw you Never know you were Doki Bird.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
New Doki just dropped this Doki Bird.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
Oh wait, wait.
Let's see.
There was some.
Oh yeah.
By the way, merch lines?
I, okay.
So I got this really, there was one thing.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope they're happy.
This is like Barney.
board jokes in the simpsons thank you super chat thank you
thank you odin thank you super chat thank you thank you i
don't know what you're talking about it is very unique thank
you super chat thank you thank you okay so obviously there's
merch at capcon cup and there was one merch that was so hard
to get it was crazy it was like a capcon cup jacket and it
was reversible it looked really sick so let me see i can
find capcon cup jacket it was always sold out every day it
was so bad it was like bad as in like it was actually like
almost impossible to get let me see i could find the no this
is the 2024 i need capcom cup 2026 because i need to show oh
my god i need to show you guys this it was a sick jacket
they better not put it online
this jacket online i swear to god i swear i'm sorry you're
like wow i can't believe it you want it to be that no you
don't understand like i hope this jacket never goes on like
for pre-orders because you don't understand you don't
understand how bad it was like it was so bad oh thank god
Okay, so this live, let me say, I took photos of this, okay,
so, um, so it was so bad to the point where like, so I came
every day, yeah, I'm gatekeeping, I'm fucking gatekeeping,
no, it's really bad, to the point where like, I asked Andy,
the staff member to, to line up for me, uh, to, you know, to
use his staff privilege, at first I asked him to use his
staff privileges to see if they could keep it, put it aside,
So that like, because each day they restock the merch.
So they're like each, you know, so like each day, you know,
people who have this ticket or that ticket or this ticket,
they'll be able to, you know, be able to get it and
everything.
So I asked, you know, first two days I couldn't get it.
And at that point I was like, I can't get it, my obviously
I'm not going on opening hours because that's crazy.
Like I show up for the matches I wanted to watch the most.
and that was supporting the bird family um i missed angry i
missed big bird matches but i got there for angry bird i
also got a picture with big bird too um um anyway so um
obviously i missed the first day because my flight didn't
arrive in time for the first day so uh so and also i was
tired so i was like at the hotel for a bit longer than i
should have uh it's like and always jacket was always sold
out the jacket was always sold out and then and then second
day i'll try it again it was sold out i came at maybe like
11 uh maybe like 12 p.m doors open apparently at 10 so i was
like that's two hours surely the jacket is still in stock
and it's still qualifying day and usually people don't watch
the qual usually don't not okay people still watch it but
not a lot not like fully packed, you know, it was like half,
like 50%.
Surely there's enough.
Nope, sold out.
So on the second day, I gave up and asked Andy, the staff
member, the Capcom staff member, if he could ask them to put
aside a jacket and save it for like us.
And then he asked and they were like, no, not even players,
employees, not even Kenny Omega.
We want it to be equal for everybody.
quality for everyone to be able to get this jacket so you
have to line up if you want this jacket and i was like damn
what not even kenny like because apparently the staff member
told me that he had to like bang to like please kenny really
want anyone please can we have a jacket and then they were
like no privileges yeah then they're like fine fine we will
let you have a jacket for Kenny.
Yeah, all are equal for the merch line.
At first they were like not even Kenny.
And then the staff was like, please, Kenny really wants it.
And they're like, alright, alright.
Well, only for Kenny.
They're only for Kenny.
Anyway, so, so so they weren't able save any more jackets
for anyone else.
Not even staff members.
Not even Andy.
Andy didn't get a jacket, by the way.
He couldn't get it for himself.
They were like, line up if you want a jacket.
He works for Capcom, by the way.
Capcom USA.
Not Capcom Japan.
But still, this man works for Capcom.
And they're like, nope.
Gotta line up if you want your own jacket, buddy.
You gotta line up with the rest of us and bro i literally
were cute and so so i was just like damn you can't even get
a jacket he's like no we gotta line up and i was like okay
but you are so i was just like okay annie but you are a
staff that means they will let you in earlier than the
regular people because it's employees only first and he's
like yeah and i was like so you can you know you can can
like uh you know just get there early and then go to the
merch line you know first thing and then he was like jokey
i'm not waking up at seven in the morning to get your jacket
i will get there the earliest at 8 30 but no much not
earlier
It's real fair.
He's like, I'm not getting there.
Like, we might be able to get there.
Like, I'm not getting there.
And I was like, okay, I'll take it.
8.30.
Surely, surely it'll be fine.
Surely, the doors don't open until 11, right?
Surely, that's early enough.
And then the next day, he was like, I got there at, he told
me, the jacket's sold out.
I was like, there's no way.
And he's like, I got there at 9.30 and it was already gone.
I was like, 9.30.
The toys haven't even, they've been lining up for that long.
I was just like, 9.30 and it was already sold out.
The jackets, by the way, the Capcom Cup jackets.
I need to see if I could find, no, you don't understand.
Those jackets go hard.
It actually go hard.
I can see why it's selling out.
I can show you the, so.
out board let me show you the sold out board um jackets do
in fact go hard i i need you guys to know that so on so day
three was a bust so day four he was like i'll wake up at
i'll get there at 8 30 this time not 9 30 but 8 30 and i was
like i'll take it out i'll fucking take it So, um, let me
see if I can grab.
Okay, it's sort of very hard to see.
I'm going to grab, like, a snippet of this and see if I can.
See, I'm going to snip.
I found the board that has the jacket.
All right.
This jacket goes so hard.
I, it does, though.
All right.
So, it's reversible.
So, this is the front.
By the way, the jacket was $100.
so I mean okay so this is the front and it's reversible in
the back though there's prints on the back you can't see it
you can't see it because it's a very shitty photo but um the
front it's so cool it's in person it looks so cool but like
um this is like it's reversible so you can reverse it and
there's like black like the the little prints on the black
part too but you can't see in the photo but I swear to God
it's really sick it's really sick but every day this shit
sells out this shit sells out so so then day four uh rolls
up on he 8 30 and he was like wait let me see if i let me
see all right let me see if i can find the text from from
him i need to show it's pretty funny it's pretty funny um
Um, okay, so he got there at 845.
All right.
And I felt like, it was like, and he was like, and wait, I
got here at 845 today, waited in line until now, and it's
sold out just now in the middle of the line.
an SDCC exclusive and then 20 minutes later never mind I got
him obviously I was like freaking out I was like what the
fuck do you mean and then I like it's over we're so back
it's over we're so back and so apparently one size was sold
out so you have to grabbed the other sides but it was not
right but it was like a roller coaster of emotion he was
like no and the crazy part was that i saw okay so i i didn't
realize how bad the line was but apparently he got that age
45 people have been lining up already for maybe more than
two hours i don't know by looks of it because he told me
when he got there the lines were already divided by three
and I was like what the fuck do you mean by three so there
was the main line where the merch booth was and then there
was a second line um past the merch booth that they had to
let in by by rounds by groups and then there was a third
line on top of the stairs and at age 45 games don't start
until 11 a.m so there were three sets of lines that he had
to go through to get to the merch store to grab my fucking
jacket i was like holy shit and he told me he lined up in
that line for two hours he was in that line for two hours
but hey got the jacket.
Well, he got the jacket.
I sort of, I sort of delegated it.
It's a weird call where you like, you give the job to
someone else instead, or it's not delegation, but I, I slept
in and went to the arena at maybe 12 or 1 p.m.
But hey, I paid for Punch the Monkey and the muscle bar i
did that no it's another word there's another word for it
where um um we're like you give this job to someone else
outsource i outsourced it to andy
he had to wake up early and buy the jacket i woke up at
maybe 12 p.m and i went to the arena and one or three could
be either i lost i lost track of what time i showed up i
hey hey i paid for everybody's muscle bar guys i paid for
the muscle bar experience um you monster anyway anyway on
the last day the last capcon cup day for the street the last
day i think it was like sunday i realized oh i sort of
wanted this other merch that i never got like i was like you
know what i wanted this other merch that and i asked annie i
was like what tom are you heading to the arena and he's like
not that early again because i was like i was like debating
really hard because i was like i didn't get the passport
there was this passport merch of the street fighter passport
that shows up in games where you try to visit all the
countries in the passport of in the game and I was like oh
that's cool I want something like I I didn't buy on the
first day because the first day was never sold out the first
and second day because there's not a lot of people so I
didn't get it because I was like not really and I was sort
of getting like buyers regret I was like oh I should have
got it so but then it was always sold out because there's so
many people there so I was like you know what I'm gonna try
lining up this time you know you know I'll get there early
so I woke up at 7 in the morning and got there around like
eight eight-ish and then they're lying i mean what i saw the
line guys because because i was like no the line can't be
that bad and i was just like and the thing is i saw the line
and then like and then in my head i was just like i was just
like i'm like i can't be that bad and i saw more of the line
and then i was like no because i wanted to help get emily
and feisty this other jacket it was like uh it was like this
gym jacket where like um it was also sold out it was just a
great for me i was like it wasn't as special as the capcom
cup jacket because it was just a gray jacket so i couldn't
understand why everybody was freaking out about this
particular jacket but it was also sold out every day so i
was so confused because like but i was like you know what
i'm getting early i might as well get that jacket for like
emily and feisty too and then like and i got there not only
was i i saw not only was it sold out it was no not only was
the line so big but at 8 a.m this is this is 8 a.m At 8 a.m.
Doors have not opened yet.
Doors at 8 a.m.
I was like, okay.
I don't even know what I can get here.
I...
What?
I don't know how long people...
Bro, okay.
Okay, I need you guys to know this.
Right here, number 22.
their potato chips, by the way, and I regret eating them.
I bought the potato chips, and I ate them.
Okay, it comes with trading cards.
There's a chance you can, you get two trading cards over
there, and you also get two potato chips.
And then I was like, I should have kept the potato chips.
What the fuck?
I did not realize they'd be so into man.
I fucking hated.
I ate the potato chips.
I gave one to Andy, and I ate the other bag.
And I was like, I knew if I knew if I knew these potato
chips were so fucking popular.
I bought this on day one It was not sold out by the way.
It was not sold out and then the potato chips I should have
kept it.
I should have eaten the lip.
I didn't know I was like it's potato chips like I didn't
even save the bag.
I threw it I'm like he threw it.
I didn't realize I did not realize because it didn't sold
out on the first day.
It just, it tasted, it was just Laze.
It tasted like Laze potato chips.
Um, I, okay, I did get the trading cards, though.
I got the trading cards.
It comes with two trading cards.
I kept those.
But I was just like, oh, this potato chips.
Let me try it out.
Annie because I was like thanks for lining up for me bro
like thanks for helping me line up later and I just ate it
and then I found out they were sold out also I got the
zanghi figure by the way I'll post it I'll display it I'll
show you guys it later not today I think after today we're
not today though but I got the zanghi figure um but yeah
like like it's crazy it's actually this sold out at 8am 8 i
i fucking saw that and i noped out i was just like no and i
saw the board and i was just like bro it's impossible i what
am i gonna do the first match doesn't start until 11th like
i just sat there for three oh yeah i almost broke into okay
because before um before there was a dressing room in the
behind the scenes vip backstage area and we were we're
allowed for kenny omega but i didn't realize on sunday kenny
was flying back to la so um so i almost broke into like the
the musical acts um dressing room like almost went in nobody
stopped me i was so confident i always said that i would be
like um just go because like i forgot to bring my pass at
one point like my friend and i like i think it was by emily
it was emily or it was emily and i we went out to 7-11 to
grab some food and we both forgot to pass it and i was like
don't worry just walk in with confidence and then we won't
know like just walk in via the vip section with confidence
and they won't know and then we did that nobody checked us
so i just do that like if i was like if i forget something
if i forget pass but i know i'm allowed in i just i just
walk in there with confidence and it works like nobody
they'll just be like you belong there and it works so i did
that for the behind the scene backstage vip room where
apparently we're not supposed to be allowed in unless we
have we're not we didn't have the right passes in but the
staff let us in because like if we're with andy like it's
fine but like it's hard they're like really strict about it
and stuff because it's like you know they don't want some
random person to go through to be backstage um but like our
passes technically doesn't have the um what's it called the
jurisdiction uh the like one level two level three pass
what's it called um the the level for it to be in behind
backstage but we're we are allowed uh not enough authority
but like anyway the clearance yeah our passes technically
didn't have the clearance to be backstage uh but we are
allowed we just you know like the regular staff won't will
not let us in but then like i went in there with confidence
so nobody stalked me so
so because like i wanted to grab some drinks um i want to
grab some water at in the dressing room because we're
allowed like uh we're allowed to um we're allowed to uh we
have permission to do so um and um and i was about to go
into the room and then the the name beside uh because we're
allowed to hang out in the dressing room too like to wait
and stuff um and um i was literally about there was a bunch
of people by the way outside the dressing room and nobody
stopped me and then i was about to open the door and then i
looked i looked at the name plate on the side and it was a
japanese name and i was like that's not kenny omega that
stopped and i turned around and walked back to the i walked
back up i let
there was like a bunch of people like i'm like supervised
like i'm pretty sure like security and stuff that that and
then i was just like oh bye
And then, and so I was just like, oh shit.
And then I, and then I, yeah, I confidently walked out
again.
It was the opening act, basically.
It was the opening, like the closing act for the, for the
entire Capcom Cup.
And I almost broke in to some, this poor dude's dressing
room.
He would be, oh my God, that would be crazy.
I was like, thank God.
I actually read the sign.
And I told Andy, Emily, and Feisty, they're like crazy.
I was like, I didn't know I thought Kenny was there.
I was like, Andy, you said we could go down there whenever
we want for water.
How else was I supposed to know?
I didn't know.
Today was the day Kenny was gone.
I was not going to be there.
I was like, did.
day was that day that he was not there don't blame Andy but
yes it was close but I succeeded oh I would show you guys
the video of the closing act but it's like it's pretty cool
it was so loud it was so fucking but like it's like there's
the lights are flashing a lot so i i just like a little bit
of a um oh it's just okay wait i'll show you a photo i got a
photo though i'll show you guys a photo i was debating okay
wait actually i could show you this it was pretty sick
though it was um it blames anyone but herself
okay um i i didn't though i didn't i i like realized my I,
like, realized that I almost fucked up, but I didn't fuck
up.
Here you go.
This was, like, this, this was the guy I almost broke into
his lock, his dressing room.
I almost, but I didn't.
It was this guy's dressing room that I almost broke into,
but I didn't.
Just remember the part where I where it didn't happen
Wait, is it miyavi?
Yes, it was miyavi.
That was the name I read Yes, it's the guitarist.
Yes, he was the closing act I almost broke into miyavi's
dressing room.
I bet I didn't do it, but I didn't I just wanted water.
I was trying to get, like, the watered.
No, it wasn't Japanese.
It literally said Miyavi.
And I was just like, wait, that's not Kenny.
Unless that's Kenny's Japanese name.
I was like, wait a minute.
That doesn't look like...
That doesn't sound like Kenny Omega.
All right, let's see.
I think it...
this is this I think it's this well well give me a sec let
me rotate this let me I always rotate this wrong whoop I did
it again there we go that's pretty sick it was so loud it
was so fucking loud but it was Pretty cool.
I can't show you guys the other video because like epilepsy
warning it the lights went hard.
It actually it went so hard Oh, yeah, it's Gaia's theme.
Yeah Yeah Um, it was so fucking loud.
I will say like um Um, it was a bit it was like Two the
three decibels too loud because like It was crazy It was so
crazy.
Also, I went to the Capcom store.
I wanted to talk about that.
I went to the Capcom store.
I would say for me, I was a bit...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, I need to show you guys this.
I bought some stupid shit at the Capcom store.
You might...
Okay, I didn't buy these, but, like, I wanted to show you
guys this.
I almost bought it.
Guess which one I almost bought?
It's pretty easy to guess, but...
Guess which one I almost bought out of all these plushies.
Guess I bought something even better.
I bought something even better.
Okay, also, if you are a fan of anything, Leon in Resident
Evil, good luck.
There's no Leon merch anywhere.
It's all sold out.
Yes, it's the
Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee-Pee,
because I was like, that's just an egg with a big ass mouth.
I like it's just what the fuck is that no it's crazy all the
Leon shit sold out is actually insane um at the Capcom store
anything Leon related buy something even better I bought
like this little spray bottle that was shaped as the
Resident Evil heel spray um wait let me see if I can Google
it Resident Evil oh nine heel spray
okay um merch resident evil oh my god it's so stupid i it's
basically it's this like let me show you it was the first
it's literally a spray that like you can fill anything you
want and it's just a little spray bottle that was the only
thing i bought at the cap concert nothing else it literally
looks like this it's the one on the left it's the it's
actually just it's like a little spray bottle where you can
put anything you want in it that's the only thing i got at
the cap concert because everything else was sold out it was
all sold out um leon related slash and then there's like
these little there was like some wester shit and like
resident evil like monsters and stuff but it did not look
that great it really it did not look that great like it's
like these little tiny plushies like the zoom zooms like the
disney zoom zooms it literally is that but like tiny but
like the like but like wester in them but it did not look
that good um okay i'll show you what i did get um at oh wait
that that's the only thing resident evil but i show you this
other thing i that was pretty worth it let me um because i
thought it was the funniest ever i don't play it that much
monster hunter but i saw that and i thought that was so
funny and i had to get it and i need to show you guys this
all right let me see this is what i got i saw it and i was
like i have to get this it
was the pp dragon but as a nightlight
it was so it's it's so worth it it's really the pp dragon
but what if it's a nightlight what if it's like look this is
what it looks like when you when it lights up
Why does it look like that?
I saw this.
I was like, I had to get it.
I can get rid of this.
I had to turn away.
So these were, I think one of the best purchases I made in
Japan.
chat is one of the most curious things I've ever seen.
I think personally, it was one of the best purchases I've
ever made in my entire trip of Japan.
Honestly, out of everything I bought, that was my number
one.
I also bought a lot of clothes.
I bought lot of clothes for my not for me obviously i think
my i didn't buy it okay the crazy part is other than jack oh
wait no i bought the universal shirt it's like 25th
anniversary but i bought a lot of clothes for my plushie
like a bit too many i will say it might have been a bit too
many but i think it was worth it i think so but it was cute
though it was was so cute like look at this wait let's see
was this the one I wait where is it but I mean look at it so
cute wait let me double check this photo like I said I don't
pre-check my photos until I do it live on stream live in New
York alright look at these I bought a lot of this I went to
a I tweeted this out and then like someone was like you
should go to Ikeburo and there's like a store specifically
just dedicated to like dressing up your newies like that's
what they're called the little plushies um and I went there
on the last day just to buy more so now I have a maid outfit
uh I have a maid outfit a spaceship outfit a little um some
hats some little decorate I bought some sunglasses I bought
so much shit it's so cute I don't know, I don't remember
what it's called, but it's in the replies for this.
Because some guy was like, you should go here if you want
more.
And I was like, I want more.
I want to dress her up.
I, so I bought even more.
I just didn't take any pictures.
Cause at that time, I was like pictured out.
I was so pictured out at that time.
I was tired.
I was like, I'm tired now.
I mean,
oh yeah I do have another story to tell but this is mint
story to tell because she's like I want to tell this story
can I tell it I was like yeah you can but just ask her about
the coins
whenever she comes back whenever she does her stream and she
talks about her trip ask her about the coin story because
she asked me if she can tell that story and I was like yeah
so I let her tell the story.
It was when we met up.
Oh yeah, they also love Thomas the Tank Engine in Japan.
I got some gotcha pot of Thomas the Tank Engine.
Bro, I saw so many cute keyboards and I'm so sad.
I can't show you guys a picture of them because like
reflection.
But like, there's so many really cool keyboards but I can't
buy any because I can't use any because I'm using...
I know I still love keyboards and stuff.
And it sucks because I use the wooden keyboard.
and the wooden keyboard is currently I have I bought the
wooden two keyboard um I have the wooden two keyboard but
it's like the best keyboard for gaming at the moment wooden
uh w-o-o-t-i-n-g it's literally like the best keyboard in
the market for gamers so it's like I have to use this
keyboard if I want to be competitive I want to play rank and
stuff so and I I got tired of swapping keyboards like I got
I got tired of swapping keyboards chat I didn't and so I was
just like fuck it so I had to stop buying keyboards because
of it because I knew I can't use I can't like use more than
one keyboard these days oh yeah there was this let me show
you guys a picture of this as well this is Kenny when he was
cosplaying as Alex and doing interviews and stuff it was
funny because they bring the backdrop onto the stage during
the interview
let's see where's the picture
this is what it looks like so like this was the main stage
the sumo arena area and then like when it was interview time
you see that backdrop they literally bring that up there and
then bring it out turn the interview portion
yeah that's really funny oh my god also if you guys were
wondering why i don't know I think like your pay the the
twitch broadcast during the free days i don't think you guys
might notice this but like um the reason why also like the
twitch ads were so long was because um during some of those
segments where the twitch ads were playing um during the
free broadcast on twitch um on stage the commentators were
shilling the merch that you could buy at the venue which was
I was like most of this was sold out.
What are you shilling for?
But that's not I realized I was watching the Twitch stream.
I was looking I was curious and like the Twitch streams They
don't show that part of the commentators being like look at
this cool merch that you can buy at the venue Like look at
this towel look at this jacket.
Whoa look at this and they would bring it out and show it to
On the TV screens and everything and
And I was looking at Twitter.
I was like, well, I wonder, like, you can only buy this
merch at the venue.
What are people on Twitch seeing?
And I pull up the Twitch screen, and it's literally like the
Capcom ads.
That's why it's longer, because literally, when you're
there, they're like chilling the merch.
So you guys get the Capcom ads, and we get the merch ads.
Like, I thought it was really funny.
that's what they're seeing
it looked cool it looked so cool it's just half of the
products were already gone half of the stuff they were
showing but it was already gone I would love to buy it if I
could and like yeah yeah tailored ads in real time I bought
a lot though i already bought a lot i bought like a but i
bought like some of the i didn't buy the towels because i
was like i i was just like all right i find okay this is why
i don't think i'm sorry i won't think i'll ever release a
towel because i think i i was like i want you guys to like
wipe your ass with my face because like they're like i was
talking to emily and feisty about this i was like oh the
towel looks sick i was like and then the towel has like chun
lee's face on it and i was like guys i don't know the towel
looks beautiful but i don't want to fucking like I want to
wipe my body with Chen Li's face like I was just like and
they're like true that's true that would be odd I was like
that's a little freaky that's a little no towel like I was
just like I was just like that's a little too freaky here so
um so I was just like I don't want the towel guys so they
were like look at this towel look at this i got like these
the acrylic boards because it was like the the capcom cup 12
artwork for it i got the zankee figure i got the potato
chips that i ate i didn't i didn't realize how fucking
valuable those goddamn potato chips were so um um so yeah i
got i i i got that like i I got the trading cards though I
got oh yeah almost broke into some mom and pops restaurant
in Japan too guys I swear to God I'm a good person like it
was just that Andy the staff the Capcom staff wanted to go
to a mom and pop restaurant and then he was like is that
like with all like all of us and I was like he was like is
that open we I can't tell because we're like I don't know it
doesn't seem open I was like don't worry guys I'll open the
door i opened the door by the way it's not locked the door
was not locked so that's why we were so confused um but no
one wanted to open the door and then i was like don't worry
guys i'll open the door like i ain't afraid i i feel like i
need like a little like like conscience to tell me to don't
do things that might be a little too reckless but like
anywhere and i was just like i'll open it i opened the door
like it was a slider doors by the way it's the slider doors
I slid the door and I looked in and everything lights were
off no lights were all fully off nobody was inside it was
very closed and I was just like guys it's not open
I was like guys it's not open there's yeah and there was no
line I I feel like I should have known when there was no
line I really, it really should have been my first, my first
like thought going in, being like, there's no line.
Maybe it's not open.
But in my head, I was like, maybe like, maybe it was just,
you know, not a lot of people.
It was just, you know, what can I say?
Just, just, it was after lunchtime.
It was just in between dinner and lunch.
So, you know, I didn't realize that it was close, close.
because I would think the door is locked the issue was that
the door wasn't locked so I couldn't tell if it was closed
or not so I accidentally broke into a mom-and-pop restaurant
I instantly closed the door when I realized it was closed so
was there really a crime committed?
I don't know
is there really a crime if I didn't technically didn't do
anything other than opening a door
the log house i'm like the pokemon i'm like i'm like link
and link just going in their people's houses and being like
where's where's the pots um in in minecraft in minecraft of
course um all right what other stuff um oh yeah by the way i
forgot to talk about this i'm looking through my log right
now my little diary that i wrote I didn't break into
anything.
Just entering.
It's not breaking and entering.
It's just entering.
Um.
Anyway.
I forgot to talk about this.
But remember when I talked about death matches and, uh,
Kenny was like talking about like, uh, telling us to go to
death matches and stuff like that.
Um.
Apparently the one of the videos where the guy was like
fucking grabbing sticks and shut, like fucking, um.
smashing into the other guy's head and like it's like it's
stuck in the head by the way that the sticks were stuck in
the head and everything the deathmashes Kojima was there
Kenny was like yeah Kojima was there watching all of this I
was like what he was crazy the video was insane Kojumbo
didn't get yeah like Kenny was like yeah yeah yeah we saw
Kojima at the deathmatch he was right there watching this
crazy ass shit Like, these guys fucking beating the shit out
of each other with, like, real weapons.
Like, that...
Kojima made this happen.
It's like, crazy.
I was like, oh, my God, Kojumbo doing the side quest.
He did it again.
Yeah, he's getting his ideas for his next game, Death
Stranding 3.
We're going to see Japanese wrestling there.
Let me see if I can find them.
I don't know if there's clips of this particular...
No.
I swear to God if you ever look up no death match wrestling
it's crazy it's like Japan death match wrestling um like I
it's it's insane I don't even know who to it's apparently
the the video was like maybe some the the wrestling
enthusiasts uh might know exactly which match it was but it
was it was like their last match or something so um it was
literally their last match and uh and like before they
retire forever like they're like rivals or some like this is
all i could give because that's what he told us um and
kojima was there watching all of it and people were like wow
and then the one thing i remember was him was them jamming
those sticks in this guy's head That's all I could that's
all I remember like
They jammed those sticks in that guy's head No apparently it
was like they've been doing for like years like decades or
some shit And I'm like holy fuck
Um Um Oh, yeah, so I'm reading my log.
So I'm going back and forth.
I'm going to go back a lot.
So also, Andy, our social media Capcom USA guy who handles
all the social media accounts.
He is particularly in currently Resident Evil account
because of Resident Evil 9.
So have you ever seen a video of like where the Leon voice
actor was reading thirst traps about himself?
Like thirst tweets about himself?
That was also his idea.
So that was Andy's idea.
good job Andy he's one of us poor the people right there
phenomenal he knows ball exactly I asked him I was like was
that your idea when he's when the voice actor was reading
was reading the thirst tweets and the and the artwork and he
was like yep that was me and I'm like poor the people Dandy
deserves a raise He did that for true He might have done
that for himself He might have been
He knows what the people That's why he's a social media
manager
My man
Let's see Oh yeah and also Kenny was so locked in During the
fight Like the Street Fighter games like oh my he was not
talking at all he was crazy watching those um uh against uh
watch also oh my god it was so like crazy but like the devs
knew who i was it was so fucking crazy because like uh when
annie was like trying like was like trying to find was
trying to find me and stuff because i was at the arena like
just watching the matches he was like oh yeah i was just
telling the devs that you're here and you're like, oh, Doki
Bird is here.
Like, they knew who I was.
I was like, oh my God, it was so crazy.
I was like, oh my God, they knew.
Like, it's just, I was like, I'm somebody.
Like, I was just like, what?
I'm, I'm...
Me?
Like...
I was like, oh my God.
Holy shit.
I can't believe it.
It's like, I'm, like, famous or something.
That's so cool.
It was so cool.
I was like, it's very, it's very, like, cool to experience.
And another thing, I don't jump in, like, back and forth,
but it's like everything I wrote in my little diary to be
like, remember to tell drag wounds this and that.
So I'm just like, I said everything I remember without
looking in my diary, and now I'm going through my diary to
be like, oh yeah, this is what I forgot about to tell you
guys.
But when the dev beat Feisty in, like, He was like, yeah!
He like turned to me and gave me a high five because he was
so fucking happy.
He's like, I did it.
I won my set.
And he turned around and just gave me a high five.
I was like, yeah!
I was like, I thought it was really cute.
And then like when we were talking, when we were like doing
his last matchup, like his last set.
or something I don't remember who he was playing against I
think he was playing against Emily he was playing against
Emily and then we were like joking about it I was like oh if
Emily beats you um we should be we should win another trip
to Japan and Emily was about to win um and then like the dev
pulled out his main because he was like obviously he like
was like Sam not Sam bagging but he tried to play like not
his main at first because he didn't want it to because Emily
was like not like uh she wasn't like master rank but the dev
was obviously because he's the fucking dev and then um and
then at the final match the final round he pulled out his
main and then he fucking locked in and won and he's like now
i win the trip to u.s it was like i win the trip to u.s
like my turn to travel i thought it was so cute i was like
yeah he's a one main he's a oh my god i don't remember
street fighter characters the blonde guy what's the blonde
guy's name also i i fucking guy must be like the worst
character they ever play against um when i was watching oh
ken he's a ken main yeah he earned yeah no No, not Gile.
I saw like a Gile versus Gile matchup and I was like this is
This is cancer to watch Like during the tournament during
the Capcon Cup like I think it was like the semis or some
shit and I watched I watched a Gile versus Gile And it was
just them throwing the stupid the the Gile Sonic boom or
whatever the fuck it was And I was just like what the fuck
is going on?
And it's just like Shoo shoo shoo shoo shoo And I was like
This is so stupid It's so fucking stupid to watch The
goddamn zoning Like Sonic Boom Sonic but then it was like
All in Japanese too So it was just I was just like In
America It's not stupid toky That sounds like a guy on me
Get him Zoner versus still in it um all right what other
stuff um oh yeah when i saw die i didn't get a picture of
diego but he's so pop for those who don't know diego he's
the guy in the let's go just the meme that did the parries
and it was fucking crazy every time he like like he doesn't
have to do anything he literally they just say diego and
then those stadium erupted in and cheers like he like sat
down and then there was like die go and i was like oh my god
it's him it's evil 37 guy he's so it's crazy um the parry
that is named after him yeah yeah it was great the stadium
was so loud um when it because like he was in the street
fighter league and um it was crazy because like he was just
it was just it's like literally like the one of the biggest
in FGC.
Yeah, the Mount Rushmore of FGC is, like, people would be
like, Daigo!
Like, literally, I hear so many shouts being like, Daigo!
I'm like, oh my god, he's him.
He's literally him.
I just say, do you enjoy fighting?
Yes, I enjoy fighting.
After all the lands I've been to, I will say, fighting game
land has to be, like, the land that I enjoy the most.
out of all of them I went to like three different lands I
was crazy and in the last two years I've been I've just been
going to lands like I'm just experiencing I've been like
this trip has been like the biggest step for me in terms of
like traveling but I'm you know I'm very careful very
paranoid and everything but this is the biggest step for me
when it comes to like meeting people and everything because
I'm always super paranoid and everything but I had so much
fun it really did I'm still very careful but it was
definitely one of the most fun trips I've ever done when
comes to japan i've been to japan a lot of times um oh a
nice story i went to nakano broadway i don't know if you
guys i don't know if i'm pronouncing it right uh is it
nakano nakano broadway okay so one of my friends told me to
go there because they're like it's better than akihabara
because it's less crowded and like uh there's like anime
figures and stuff like that and then i was like okay i'll
head over there um and then like i didn't realize how much
porn and hentai there was there
this i i swear to god so i i was like there's a lot of sick
hand stuff obviously but like i was like okay so there's a
lot of mandrake stories for those who don't know what the
mandrake story is it's basically um it's basically like uh
it's basically a secondhand store so there's a lot of them
and so i looked outside the walls and it was like that's all
like you know dojin she dojins and a lot of there's like
super hardcore um how do i know this well um i looked at a
store and then the outside windows was like you know was
like acrylic stands of enemies i know and i was like oh
there's like uh acrylic stands uh figures merch um lots of
you know not hentai stuff and then i was like oh cool i want
to go inside and i saw like all that stuff too on the
outside of the windows too so i was like oh that's cool i
mean go inside that seems safe inside it was all books and
i'm like that's weird that's just like i go inside and it
was all books so i thought that was weird and i was like oh
maybe like the merch stuff the merch stuff i did not go to
the yowie dungeon it was i'm sorry guys for those who were
expecting yowie it was not yowie dungeons by the way i went
how do i know this let me don't worry you'll find out later
on the story i went inside and And then I was just like, oh,
there's a lot of books.
I mean, like, let me, maybe it's deeper in the store.
So I went deeper in the store and I was going through like
one of the hall, the, the halls for it, like the, I don't
know what's called the alleys and stuff.
And I was stuck in a traffic jam because there's only room
enough for one person.
So like I had to wait for a person in the front to leave,
but they were talking with a staff member about something.
I don't fucking know what, but they were blocking the exit.
then um and then i looked i turned it back and somebody was
blocking me in the back because they were looking intensely
at the books to see like you know i guess they were trying
to find their book and then i was just like oh well let me
look at these books so i wonder what books they are I turned
to my left and host mother of bazangas.
I was like, those are some town-ass boobs.
And then, oh my God, she's naked.
And then I looked to my right.
Oh my God, there's all naked women.
It was just like, it's everywhere.
Oh, I hope those white substances on the cover are like not
not not real by the way It's just the illustration.
I hope that's just illustrations of cream from cooking I was
like, oh my god I was stuck there for like five minutes I
was It surely is just, she's just drinking milk, right?
Anyway, so I was stuck in this, I realized what store I was
in.
And so,
yeah, so it was just, I got stuck there, right just looked
straight ahead I just just looked straight ahead waiting for
the staff member to finish waiting for the the customer and
the staff to finish talking and it was like it was like a
girlfriend boyfriend to get it talking with I was like I
guess share your hobbies and interests together I guess they
shared i guess they shared a common hobby i guess if they're
here together i was like damn i'm the tree yeah the goals i
don't know couple goals i guess um thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you um going out to get milk sound kind
of dip so that's basically what so i waited and then whoa i
got out i got anyway and i told my friend i was just like
bro what the fuck like you you said this is like akia bar
where there's like anime figures and all he's like and but
you didn't tell me about the hentai shit and the dolgens and
like r-a-t-d-dolgens and the porn and he's like oh yeah when
i was there last time there was a gotcha paw machine that
was
and i was just like that was information that you might have
omitted
so i thought i was like i thought that was just you know
just me
i got to mention some crucial information so apparently
there's also a gotcha pond that also that the kind of
broadway no that's that's for real that's yeah um i i'm
fortunately or fortunately i don't know what you guys would
say think but for me fortunately i mean i wanted to take a
picture of it i i i would not not just the machine not i
would not gotcha pond it just the machine guys just the
machine i wanted to take a picture of the machine and be
like look what i found but like i didn't find it i didn't i
didn't find it guys um um thank you thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you um it's crazy because like someone
said it but nikano broadway the kanobadwe they they also
have like watches to like thousand dollar plus watches like
in the store might be next to like a hentai store like a
hentai dojin store and it's just like whiplash it's it
really is it's like you don't expect it but they're next to
each other uh it's like It's just like, I guess it's the
market.
I guess it's a target audience.
Let's see.
What else?
Yeah, oh yeah.
And then there's a small cafe around the corner.
Um, what else?
Oh yeah, we went to the Kuro revolving sushi.
and we had as a team we ate 70 plates it was crazy feisty
can eat a lot like she was she was like a team player she
was like I got this tuna like six plates of tuna she's like
they're all for me guys I was like oh my god that's a lot I
love tuna guys I just love tuna and we yeah we was like to
be fair there was a lot of us it was like two of the three
of the Capcom staff and then it six people so we had 70
plates in total out of six of us which is like you know if
you think about it it's like 10 ish plates per person we
were so hungry though we were so fucking hungry so it's not
that bad if you think about it um so kura is so if you guys
ever go to japan and you want revolving sushi recommendation
i would suggest kura over sashiro i did i tried And I like
Kira more It was 70 plus plates It was not just 70 It was
like 70 plus plates
Yeah It was so good I wish Revolving sushi was popular Like
outside of Japan I think it was like There used to be a lot
of revolving sushi Back then But I think COVID closed up a
lot of them
Oh yeah it was so funny Oh my god I forgot about this Um And
oh i almost forgot about this it was so funny so before we
went to the muscle bar so their muscle bar has like
scheduled times we had to show up so we were eating at a
really nice restaurant with all this it was like our last uh
our last meal that capcon paid it was the last day
technically for capcon cup and it was like their last meal
with the staff and um also kura is a lot better Japan than
like outside of and uh and then in NA for sure they had a
lot more options and a lot cheaper too but anyway uh so we
had our last meal together as a staff so um it was really it
was like uh for muscle bar it was special reservation so we
have to get there by uh um we have to get there before uh
before it closed like before uh our appointment because like
you know they they'll give up our seats and we don't get
there in time and it was a really good restaurant it was
like skewers um i remember what it's called in japanese but
it was like a skewer restaurant and it was so fucking good
and then we each wanted to order one of wait let me see i
have a photo of it too oh i also ate horse meat not only did
i eat horse meat we ate uk horse meat like i was like this
is okay this is emily mixing it um and then i i suggested it
by the way I was like, we should get horse meat.
I was like, guys, have you guys had horse meat?
But we should get it.
I was like,
right after the horsey game, too.
Like, right after the horsey game, right after we played the
horsey game together, chat.
I was like, we gotta eat horse meat.
But yeah, so that's horse meat, by the way.
It's like the raw horse meat, too.
Like, I didn't even want them to cook it.
how that hungry so this is uk which is like mixed horse meat
mixed with egg yolk and everything it's weird so so yeah i
had uk horse meat too not just regular i didn't even wait
for them to cook the horse meat i raw horse meat it was good
though that was fire anyway let me give you guys let me show
yes the yakitori so we had it was so good the place was like
i think it was the best restaurant we've ate so far we ate
that that so far in japan um you monster anyway this is like
it looked good and it was good um and um anyway so we
ordered each ordered oh my god let me show you guys the
picture it was so funny um So, let me see, I could find the
picture.
Travel to Japan.
So, we were waiting for the dessert, but for some reason,
the dessert was taking so long to get there.
And at that time, we were like, we have to go.
We can't, we can't keep like, oh my God, it's been five
hours of yapping.
I'm so sorry.
It's five hours of yapping.
I'm sorry.
happen and I miss talking to you guys um anyway so um um it
was like getting too late so we were like all right we have
to go but one staff didn't so it was like two staff members
it was Andy and the other staff um I don't know if I can say
his name because I didn't ask uh his permission I could say
his name um so uh and then it was you know me feisty and
Emily and then Andy was coming with us because it was like
girls night you know yeah girlies dang and and then um and
the other guy was like nah i'm like like he he was like i'm
not gonna go because like at that time like reservation was
super hard so like we couldn't grab an extra ticket for him
um unfortunately because like um it's like it's so weird the
reservation is like the maximum you can buy is four and then
you have to buy a separate one after that so we couldn't
grab like a separate section um and then so um and then um
so he was like i'll stay here and then we're like well god
we can't couldn't we ordered one of each dessert and then
the dessert never the dessert didn't arrive in time because
we had to leave to get to our reservation for the muscle
girl bar and you guys already saw it was so worth it guys it
was so worth it the muscle girl bar it was so fucking worth
it like in the end we got up and then like literally as we
left the restaurant because he stayed um and then at first
he wanted two of every dessert to be like so like you know
it's like everyone we should get two of every dessert so
that everyone can have a chance to have some and i was like
no and then i cut in and was like no we should just get one
of each because like i think that's too many dessert guys
and then they're like oh you're right maybe we'll just grab
one of each so thankfully I stopped the two of each dessert
and then so finally all the desserts arrived and and it
literally they literally arrived after we walked for like
three minutes so we stayed for three minutes lot we didn't
get to eat it all Andy Emily Feisty and I we didn't get to
eat it the other staff was like dessert landed dessert was
and then we were like what's the dessert good and then and
then he sent and then he sent this fucking photo to us
good he replied back oh yeah i think it was like who said it
oh feisty was like how was it and he replied back with this
picture and wrote good
My man ate
Before he ate all of it himself He ate all of it himself
Wait again It looked so good too The dessert looked so sad
It looked so good Guys What a champ so um we couldn't get to
the third our other staff member did i mean we had to make
it in time we'll miss out on the muscle mobbies you don't
understand it was we would miss out on the muscle mobbies
and we didn't make it in time like
oh my god the sacrifices we had to make chat it was It was
sacrifices we need to make.
Oh yeah, during the maid cafe.
By the way, on the last day with Emily, me, and Feisty.
Because Feisty was staying at Wild and me too.
I was staying a couple days longer.
Emily had to leave, like, on her.
She debated for a long time whether to stay or not.
But she's like, I'm going home.
I have a lot of stuff to do anyway.
I have a lot of work stuff today.
She was more responsible than us.
She was older than us.
So of course she was, like, the more responsible out of the
three of us.
So, you know, she made the right decision in going home.
because like she got work she needed to get work done me on
the other hand i got home and i played overwatch so um
that's a little bit of a me issue just a little bit anyway
um so so all of us were like what should we do i was like we
should go to make like she was like i want to go to a maid
cafe because i want to experience the maid cafe she did do a
maid cafe a long time ago like 10 plus years ago um and so
she wanted to experience maid cafe and i was like we should
go to dreaming because like that was like from what mint
told me was like the maid cafe to go to if you're new to
maid cafes and oh my god those maids those maids took so
much money out of emily and i they they took a lot of money
from us but like we consented to be fair we did consent to
it we were like okay so the thing is i never got to go to
maid dreaming this was my first time at made dreaming
because the last time mint tried to take me to made dreaming
um you know this was the time where instead of going to made
dream we went to this random isa kai maid cafe that was like
from one of the maid girls that was just outside um
advertising but it was still a pretty fun experience the isa
kai one which was really nice but made dreaming i we wanted
she wanted to take me there as my first experience but i
never got a chance to experience it because it was it was
full like it was so full and but apparently during lunchtime
if you want to go to made dreaming lunchtime is the perfect
time to go to it because it's like pretty empty it was like
maybe like three tables full um and then so let me see if i
can grab the photo so oh god really cute we got the omu rice
i got the mentaiko oh we all got the mentaiko omu rice it
was so i love mentaiko um but um it's a little pro tip for
people who want to try out and make cafes but lunchtime is a
perfect time to go to it because uh it's like literally like
the easiest time to go to you might not have the most maids
on but like you know it's still it's still a maid cafe but i
got i got a dog mine's a dog i got wow um i asked for a
doggo and then uh emily and feisty got cats um so yeah
apparently the top says moe um anyway they drained my bank
accounts because like i couldn't help it um i got everything
i bought every i got like i got checky oh my god wait i need
to show you guys the checky did i take photo of the checky
oh my god it was like what it was apparently one of the
maids anniversary event i'll show you guys later because i
forgot i take a photo of it but um it's um uh it was one of
the maids anniversary event so oh my god there were two one
of two of our biggest fans were there i also got the orange
glow stick by the way i paid for the full special like it
was a hundred dollars and i paid for the full experience i
got everything i got the made dreaming song i finally
realized where the made dreaming song came from i he's crazy
i never connected in my head where the fuck that made
dreaming song came from that mint sang during the phantom
thief concert it never connected in my head um but it came
from this cafe like i finally heard the song i was like
that's where it came from um anyway cute girl dream who
couldn't relate papa swear thank you super chat thank you
thank you i understand now it's actually a really good song
no it's pretty addicting um it was stuck in my head for a
long time um and i already forgot what it's i already forgot
how it goes but like it was stuck in my head for like a day
or two after i listened to it again um um um anyway um it
was crazy because it's like um two of our biggest fans were
there and i swear to god like um i i i got us a performance
because i was like oh you guys gotta see a live performance
from a main you gotta see a you know like you know that's
like what everyone does and so i that's why i got the full
experience because i wanted to like you know we also did
like they made us do the moist the moy moy stuff and then
like all the the jet hand stuff the gesture stuff the they
be shot like emily and i we got the full experience she got
the other stuff the other interactive stuff that i didn't
buy and then i bought the full experience with like um with
like performances glow sticks i got the orange damn orange i
didn't bring it home by the way because it was one use only
so i just used it for the made dreaming song and then and
then i didn't realize you know when i buy the because like
oh my god we couldn't take photo obviously we couldn't take
photos of You have to pay for it.
But I didn't realize when you...
Because, like, the performance, too.
You have to pay for, like, the performance.
The performance footage version.
So, obviously, I paid for the performance where you can film
it.
Because, like, I was like, oh, you know, for all...
You know, I want Emily and Fica to be able to film it, too.
And he'd be like, oh, it's the experience.
But I didn't realize it means everyone else could also film
it.
It's like, I was like, oh, I paid everyone.
I gave everyone a free performance.
So everyone instantly took their cameras out and started
filming it.
And I was like, wait a minute.
I thought it was just our table.
Yeah, thanks for your donation.
I'm so kind.
I'm so fucking kind.
Yeah, it's like round for everyone on me, guys.
Yeah, it's on me, everyone.
I paid for the entire maid cafe.
I thought it just went to my table.
Yeah, this rounds on me, everyone.
So, anyway, but the thing is, the maid came up to us and was
like, it was like, oh, your performance number four.
And I was like, number four.
And I was just like, I thought, and then because it was this
maid's anniversary her two biggest fans were there and like
to the point where like she like moved to the like they put
like one of the sorry one of her biggest fan bigger than the
other fan like the biggest biggest fan was there like she
had it was like a girl and she had all her merch is so cute
she had all her merch and everything um and everything and
then like and it was holding like her fan and stuff and then
she was they like moved her to the center so cheer on her
favorite maid so then um but then like you know they're like
no recording no recording and then like it was like three
performances just for her like she bought three performances
basically from for this maid and you know i was like damn
that's yoshi i was like because emily was like she was emily
and feisty were like this is her new her new like this is a
new experience for them so i was explaining to i was like
yeah like she's her biggest fan so like that's like her
favorite maid so like she's like you know supporting her
because it's her birthday it's the whole like culture and
everything and then after they did my song you know the
rounds on me girl like because at first like no photo no
video no video guys no video and then my performance came
out everybody amazed like you can video this and then
everyone pulled out their camera and i was like wait a
minute I thought I didn't realize it's for the whole cafe
and then after um my performance was done um after my I'm so
generous it was all obviously I I wanted everyone um it was
for everybody you know quality here um and then um anyway
and then it was done and then there was three more
performances from the the biggest fan from the girl for the
same maid like for the you know the her favorite maid and i
was like holy shit girl oh my god girl let her rest i'm i
was just like three more and i was like oh my This is your
biggest fan right there.
Cherish her.
I was like, and then throughout all of this, we were, Feisty
and I, were waiting for our parfaits throughout all of this.
We, Emily got her parfait.
We were, we waited through eight performances and we still
didn't get her parfaits.
So we were like, where the fuck is our ice?
ice cream like so we were like where's our ice cream we're
still so like we thought we would get our ice cream by then
so like after we were done with our omurais um we were still
waiting for our for ice cream and we were so confused
because like i said we've it's been you know it's been 45
and then finally we saw it I was like I looked at the
kitchen I was like guys I see our part face because we
ordered the pattern I'll show you guys what it looked like
because I we were like I see it guys I think I see it and
you're like are you sure I was like yes it's the pandas it's
the fucking pandas it has to be ours and so we wanted to eat
the part you wanted to eat the ice cream while watching the
performances so we were a little bit like we're like where
is it like the performances were done but still no parfait
so i was so confused i and then so here's our parfait it's
very cute it is and then and then the maid finally came out
and we were like this has to be it And then she walked to
the table next door and we were like, there's no way.
We literally saw her bring the parfait and then walk to the
table next to us.
And then we were like, there's no, we were literally so
loud.
We were like during that moment because we were like,
there's no way that that was not our parfaits.
and then and then the people on the next table was like we
didn't order
they're like we didn't order this and then we're like it's
here it's here we're like we were gonna crash out we're
legitimately this close to crashing out because we're like
there's no fucking way the table next door who came there
later than us ordered the same two parfaits that feisty and
i ordered there's no fucking way so it was ours and we were
so close we're gonna crash out if like that that table that
was actually the other table is parfait it was it was ours
it was ours we were so close we're like we're so close to
the parfait we're so close to crashing up but it was really
cute it was very cute it was still a really great experience
we got like I mean we got eight fucking we got eight
performances from that maid cafe um it was crazy we I was I
you know I didn't realize um like how well to be fair all of
it was from the super fan but like hey eight free seven free
sorry free performance the eighth one was my but seven free
performances i i take those you know like
i take those i get to watch seven free performances and then
the eighth round was on me
yeah no yeah and i got checky where one of the uh the
anniversary the special made like the anniversary made held
my uh held my uh plushie it was really cute i'll show you
guys a picture of that later i'm too lazy to take a photo
right now um i have to unpack it from my suitcase yeah i
don't want to unpack right now it's like in my suitcase guys
um oh yeah by the way um for those who like um um let's see
oh yeah for those who are like never took the bullet train
no i haven't unpacked i literally like my luggage my fucking
luggage is just in front of my door i've not even brought it
into my apartment um i didn't even bring it to my apartment
or in my room it's just in front of my fucking entrance i
just left it there and it was like that's how i'm gonna do
it for now that's but i forgot to tell you guys this but if
you guys ever do a bullet train do reserve seats don't be
like me i i because like i treated feisty to trip to
universal you know it's like um because i wanted someone to
come with me to universal and and we did i did un no reserve
seats because i was like surely it's okay so what i didn't
realize is that it's only two it's a very long bullet train
and then it's only two train two uh sections that are just
unreserved everything else is reserved and i didn't know
that so we went in and just sat because we're like surely we
didn't really read so we're like we just went in and thought
this was the unreserved area because we're like surely this
is unreserved so we just sat down and then and then feisty
was like wait what did they say what does that what does
that say reserve i was like i don't know i can't really see
it so far and i was just like um And then I was like, surely
it's fine.
There's so many empty seats.
Like, we can just sit here for a bit.
And then the moment I said that, some guy literally just
walked by us and was like, this is my seat.
Like, showed me the ticket.
And I was like, oh, I'm so sorry.
There's so many empty seats.
And then, of course, we picked the ones where the seat was
taken.
And the rest of the seats around us were empty.
and we sat in the one seat we sat on the one seat where like
where like the guy was like this is my seat and showed me
the ticket and I was like oh shit I'm so sorry and but yeah
there's only two cars that was unreserved and it's all the
way to the end which by the way like we got there the moment
the door is open but if we knew that which cars was the
unreserved we could we still got seats in the end but like
feisty had to sit behind me not to sit in the front but like
and then yeah but like if we got there and we realized which
one was the unreserved we could have like um sat together we
just sit together in the end because like uh a guy in my
area section left so then we could sit closer to the we sat
we sat together after the halfway point um um but it was
like i was just like oh my god i'm so embarrassed i was like
and then when we came back i booked the reserve seats i
booked a bougie reserve seat the green car where we can
recline our seats in um like royalty i was just like give me
that good shit i stood in line for like i stood in too many
lines today i need that green car with that green money
right there um anyway grab the green car when you're going
it it's so worth it guys that green car that they have like
a seat rest and everything it's not as it doesn't it's not
like um i would say like it's not as like the the prices the
green car and the regular reserved seats it's not that big
of a difference yen wise so it was 100 percent worth it i
was so tired i fucking slept like 80 of that ride back also
don't get the i would say do not get the bento box where
it's just shaped like the bullet where the box is the bullet
train box not great it is not good get the other bento box
Bento boxes that are shaped like regular bento boxes.
I will say, we tried the one that was like the bullet train,
and it was pretty bad.
You have to get the bento boxes.
Yeah, those are for children.
I should have expected that.
I was like, oh, that's cute.
I also threw it away.
Because I couldn't keep it.
I was just like, how do I like bring this back?
i was just like you know what it's made of plastic i feel
like there's no reason for me to at first i was like i
should keep it you know maybe i'll be useful but then i was
like i'm gonna throw it away i'm gonna throw it away it
takes too much space and it's like pretty gross like even if
i i feel like i can't wash it enough to like clean it
because of it i have to travel so long and everything i'll
be at universal for like i don't want to put it in my bag
it's like what if it opens and stuff falls out like um but
yeah oh another thing i wanted to tell you guys um when i
did the minion ride there was like this little minion door
and it was like let me see if i can grab it and i took a
picture of it i know i don't remember if i took a picture of
this but i thought it was so funny because of the child's
reaction um oh i didn't but i did take a picture of this
though i'll show you guys don't worry it's worth it it's my
hero wait actually let me see if there's reflection it's my
hero but i still gotta be safe
all right okay give me a sec i'm gonna put this in paint
all right thank god um actually i can just do it in
photoshop there is a reflection i have to i have to let me
help make sure this is safe
oh my god photoshop is taking so long yes unfortunately I am
still a subscriber to Adobe.
I'm no, my,
unfortunately.
I'm still with, I'm still a subscriber.
Oh no.
Shame.
Nothing I can do.
all right let's see all right there you go all right i got
it all right here you go i'm gonna put this up while i tell
my little story
all right the reason why that is cropped out is because it's
a fucking wind it's a reflective window
So I had to crop out the entire window.
And it was El Macho.
It's El Macho.
Yes.
It's...
All right.
Okay, so in the minion ride, there was like this, like,
event area.
It was like this event area where, like, you know, they're
doing, like, the introduction to, like, the game.
It was the minion ride.
And then there was, like, this giant door and then this tiny
door.
It was like probably a prop, but then like you would hear
minion sounds coming out from the little door.
It was really cute.
You know, it was very immersive.
Um, I guess El Macho.
It's my hero El Macho.
Anyway, so, so it was really cute.
I thought it was like super immersive.
How, and then this little kid ran up to the fucking tiny
door and started kicking it.
It's like, like, she started, he started kicking this little
door really hard.
after the mom was like get back here he's like trying to
yank the kid back and then after she yanked it back and then
the little door was making the minion sounds and then the
little kid came back and started kicking the door again and
then and like the yank the mom's arm away from him and
started kicking the door again and then i was so confused i
was like why is that why is she doing this why is she doing
it and then the mom was like why stop why are you doing this
and then There's minion sounds coming from it, but it's a
fake minion.
There's no minion in there.
How dare they fake a minion?
I want to see if it's real, but I know it's not real.
They're trying to fake a minion that's in there.
It's like he's so mad.
That little kid was so mad that like, it wasn't a real
minion.
Because he thinks minions are real.
And then so he was mad at like the ride for like faking
minions.
in the tiny door like making minion sounds and like the
magic was broken so like it's like he found out Santa wasn't
real and like so the kid was so angry because he was like
why are they faking minions in that in that door like that's
not where the minions are where are they that's a fake
minion and like Peter damn Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's like he just found out minions aren't real like this
whole trip was over for him Because he he finally realized
minions weren't real because of the minions, right?
So he started like kicking the door like being like you're
fake you're not real you're fake
So, I was just like, what the, I had to write it because I
was just like, what the fuck?
I was just like, damn, kid, I'm sorry.
My condolences, little child.
I'm sorry, little bro.
This is how you had to find out.
Damn.
Minions ride.
Destroyed his world.
I also found Snoopy and forgot about Snoopy's world.
Look at this.
I thought this was...
The doctor is in.
I'm the assistant.
I...
He just wanted to be in his heroes.
No way.
oh yeah almost forgot to start wait i'm gonna grab water
real quick
i almost forgot to tell this so past dokey okay this is like
this is another issue with past dokey and present dokey or
future dokey so um past dokey so i was okay so when i was
gonna check out for my hotel um by the way pro tip if you
ever book a hotel i would 100 recommend doing hotel
apartments instead of regular hotels they are they're
usually cheaper than hotels and also you get more room the
only issue is that they don't clean the room every day it's
like every three days but like i honestly personally think
apartment hotels is just so it's much better to stay at and
like for a better price and better location too there's a
lot it's like sometimes they're usually like in a better
location as well um so he's a pro tip apartment hotels is
like the i i personally think it's just like best to say all
right all right i don't trust i personally just don't trust
airbnbs because of all the fees that they add on top of it
um because like there's a chance you might get an airbnb
where they add like all these random fees and stuff so like
um i personally don't like doing airbnbs because of it but i
i just like i like apartment hotels the most um And it comes
with a washer and dryer, too.
In the apartment, in the one-year stay, in the apartment
hotel.
Or cameras, yeah, too.
Anyway, so, so I was checking out.
I was so confused.
Because when I was checking out, they were like, you have
one more day.
You know that, right?
And I was just like, what?
And I was like, I didn't really, but it was like, in a bit
of like, broken English.
understand that he was telling me that i still have one more
day and i was like no i don't i'm checking i was like what
do you mean like today's my flight why would i have one more
day like but my like i was so confused but my fight was
later in the day but i was just like and i was confused
because i was like oh why didn't it not call me to check out
at 11 a.m like i was like late to checking out because i
went downstairs at around 12 p.m so i was so confused i was
like You know, I was, it's 12.
I'm a bit late to check out because I was packing.
And yet, I didn't get a call or, like, a warning or
anything.
And so, also, someone was, like, love hotels are very cheap
and get clean, very meticulously.
You would think that.
I heard about that, too.
But, like, then I heard a lot of horror stories being, like,
you're not as clean as you think they are.
Like, never stayed in one.
But, like, I heard people saying that they're not as clean
as you think they are.
and also you're gonna hear a lot of noises apparently from
like from the the reviews i've heard about yeah yeah um
anyway so i was so confused i was just like what do you mean
warmer day so apparently and then i realized the moment i
finalized my checkout i realized i booked an extra night and
i was so i was like oh my god so i lost one day of I lost
one day of because apparently I can't do math so I was just
like did I forgot that counted wrong did past Doki counted
wrong and accidentally booked an extra day and then I
realized past Doki was just too smart for present Doki
because her plan was that she booked an extra night because
she thought I could just leave my suitcase there and then
after I'm done with everything I could come back and pack
later before I go to my flight she was too smart for me
because my flight was later at night so her plan was that oh
she didn't have to rush to pack in the morning she could
just have a good day and then like not have to wake up too
early to pack at before 11 a.m.
checkout and then so she can Whatever she wants, come back,
pack, and then go to the airport.
Korin Doki at that time forgot all about this plan because I
did not write that down.
Past Doki forgot to write, did not write this down for Korin
Doki because she thought she will remember this.
I didn't remember it at all.
So I woke up early, packed everything, checked out, and then
it clicked in my head that I had an extra night.
Because for some reason, the receptionist was like, are you
sure you want to check out?
You still have one day left, and I was so confused.
I was like, yeah, I want to check out.
What do you mean by that?
And then it clicked in my head.
And they're like, you okay?
And I was like, yeah, I'm okay.
And then after I did everything, they're like, you're good
to go now.
I was just like, oh my God.
Past Doki booked an extra night, so I didn't have to fucking
pack until later.
I...
Past Doki's plan almost worked.
It almost did.
because past Doki was like she's gonna buy more stuff she's
definitely gonna have to buy more stuff um before her flight
so um so at least it'll give her time to pack the extra
stuff before she went instead of doing that I brought two I
was holding two extra bags on top of my regular bag to the
plane because obviously I couldn't repack because I already
packed up I She had a plan, but just couldn't execute it
because I forgot the plan.
I am not spoiled by those meddling donkeys that didn't
account for the fact that President Donkey is dumb.
I am my biggest enemy.
I...
When you are too smart for your own good sometimes, it's all
it's taking.
give the super chat thank you thank you i can't believe i
forgot the plan so i lost one night at the hope there's no
refund so i lost one night oh anyway but yeah i i i forgot
it but i always forgot about that story but good thing pass
jokies this time wrote it down so she could tell you guys
the experience of how fucking stupid i am i i almost forgot
but this time i wrote that story down this time um i did it
i mean um um oh yeah when i met met on the When I met Mint,
I was like, what do I want to do?
Because I was like, you decide what to do.
Because she was a really busy one.
I was the semi-busy.
I was so busy, but not as busy as her.
I was having a vacation.
She was there for work.
And then she's like, oh, let's get afternoon tea.
And then I was like, all right, you decided time.
Because I went by her schedule.
And then afternoon was passing by.
And I was like, this is not...
I was like, oh.
You know, I was just like...
this is not after and then by the time it was like past five
by the way it was like past five and i was like are we still
getting afternoon tea i even took a nap i was like i'm tired
i'm too tired right now i'm gonna go take a nap no wake up
and it's like almost seven and then i was like this does not
seem afternoon no more like what like i was just like i
don't know what is after Apparently, did I get the
definition wrong of what afternoon tea is?
And we ended up getting afternoon tea.
We got afternoon tea at the evening.
It was evening tea at that point.
It's still, yeah, it's still afternoon.
And then she's like, oh yeah, let's meet up here.
And I was like, all right, cool.
I'll go ahead over now.
Thank God I like, I woke up from my nap in time to receive
the text being like, oh yeah, you free that blah blah blah
and I was like yeah yeah I can head over like I was like
getting worried because I was like did something happen I
thought we getting afternoon tea I'm pretty sure like 6 p.m.
it's not afternoon I so I was like oh it's no it's 12 it's
yeah I can get afternoon tea And then it started being like
two.
And I was like, I mean, it's still afternoon tea.
Two at two is fine.
And then it started getting four and five.
And I was just like, I'm going to take a nap.
I'm going to take a nap now.
So I thought that was funny because I was like, I was
panicking a little because I was just like, this is way, I
don't know if we're at the afternoon anymore.
I'm having trouble figuring up this is afternoon guys
All right, what else what else oh, yeah, but yeah, I did
like I said, I did go to like her maid cafe She took me to
her maid cafe.
It was fun.
It was a fun.
It was really cool.
It was like it's like It was a tiny like homey maid cafe and
there was like so like the merch was really really cute Um,
oh, yeah, like Oh my gosh, I forgot to tell you guys I made
dreamies um there was a little gotcha poll that we could do
where we could win like various prizes i was i was like i
got the tiny ass button mine was a tiny ass button i got the
and then and then emily got like a cheque photo like a photo
of the maid and then feisty got a giant ass folder and mine
was a fucking tanya's one size of a hundred yen coin button
and then i forgot and by the way by the way guys the gotcha
was 800 yen it was eight it was 800 yen and the worst part
was that i forgot to put it in my bag because it was so tiny
so i lost 800 yen so but but not all hope was lost guys
because I still I took a photo of the button guys not all
hope was lost because I took a photo of the button so at
least I have the memory of it good morning welcome back I
hope you had a nice vacation thank you for the super chat uh
to you get thank you thank you I did I had so much fun I
mean I've been yapping for six hours talking about this
vacation but yes guys look I still have the photo 800 yen
for a photo of the button because I was like this button is
so fucking tiny and they were all it's technically still
there in our hearts
so tiny though i i didn't even get i didn't even fucking get
to keep it because i forgot about it i fucking left it i
fucking left it at the um at the fucking maid cap because i
forgot to i forgot to put it um i'm so bad with gotcha i
also did the other gotchas another like those lottery
gotchas um the lottery gotcha thing um for Mint's maid cafe
and then we both pulled it I'm not gonna spoil what Mint got
but she was like you should pull first and I was like why me
first and
I'll just say she got a lot better prize than me I pulled
the lottery gotcha I got a fucking tanya sticker I didn't
even know how much I spent on that lottery I'm just giving
her money at that point I got and then she she got a prize
she got definitely a lot better than mine so she wanted me
to take the bad luck it was of her I got like all the shit I
got was literally I did like the gotcha pod machine with the
buttons and then the the um the what was it called the uh
placemat thing it was just her i just got all of her i
didn't even get like i am my her mama ayamame um ayami i'm
sorry i don't know i don't remember how to pronounce it but
i didn't get her i was just like what the what are the odds
i didn't get her mama it was just all men and then i didn't
um and then like but yeah i did the lottery thing and it was
the fucking i swear to god it was also the size of a hundred
yen it was
It was the tiniest mint sticker.
It was...
I got like the worst, like the lowest number in the fucking
lottery.
I got the lowest number in the lottery.
And it was a fucking tiniest mint sticker.
And that was the size of like 100 yen.
I...
I would you know what it's in my bag let me I will grab this
and then I'll grab a hundred yen in comparison let me grab
it real quick
okay thank god okay the mint sticker is a little bit it's
like 200 yen okay it's that's okay to be fair this it's
there's a background of a square over the mint sticker so
like if it was just mint herself she is the size of 100 yen
she the square compensates it i'm gonna take a picture now
so i will stop moving for a little bit so
you guys can for those who know how big 100 yen is it is not
that big oh yeah i want to show you guys the stand i got too
because i thought it was pretty funny
this over i'll do this thing where i buy like these oh she's
things like these things that you're supposed to like use
for your oh she like like the the little bags the little
hangers i bought like ribbons and stuff where you can put
for your buttons and stuff um like for those who know what
i'm talking about you guys know what i'm talking like for
those who like know like the oh she culture i bought all of
those because i just want to put my face on it because i'm
my oh she Like, y'all understand when I show you guys
before.
I literally bought it because I was like, I don't put my
face on it.
Like, like, yeah.
Yeah, I'll make my Ita bag of my own face.
I'm my own biggest fan.
I'm Doki Bird's biggest fan.
But let me show you this.
I think this would...
I showed this to, like...
Man.
And she was like, where the fuck did you?
Because she wanted this as well.
And I was like, wow, this is it.
I'm y'all on me.
I'm checking for reflection real quick.
Alright, this is cool.
This is really cool.
Let me show you guys.
Before I show you guys the sticker.
I'm checking for reflection right now.
because it has it's like a bit reflective okay that's good
okay okay
you might if you're confused about this so basically it's
like the billboard of like tom square but and you put the
photo the checky in there so like my plan is
check you on here so it's like I'm on the billboard of time
square I thought it was really I thought it was cool I also
bought like ribbons and stuff where you can hang your
buttons on ribbons and I'm a big fan of dokey bird um yeah
yeah so I thought it was really funny I thought it was it's
like it's a photo frame it's like checky frame exactly so i
bought this because i thought that was really funny anyway
back down the coin now time i got all the bad luck out of
the way let me save this real quick
all right
yeah but all right
and jokie bird is the biggest fan of dokey bird exactly I
have a lot of those by the way I have like those like the
the hangers too I have the hangers and I use it to hang my
my face on it too like the checky face and now I have like I
bought those pouches I bought the plushie pouches so when
everyone else finally gets a dokey bird pouch I can hang my
dokey bird pouch on my bag would be suspicious I can be my
biggest fan I bought those doll pouches too so I can hang my
pouch out there like the other like the other guys all right
here you go here's how I need to stop here you guys go so I
think I paid more than 800 yen I don't remember how much the
lottery was but I definitely I definitely paid under 800 yen
for the lottery of this I just died and I was like yeah I
did it was it was literally the the the lowest prize you can
get it was the lowest prize you can get and oh min will i'm
pretty sure min will tell you guys what she got what
compared to me she'll tell you what she got hey oh it's 900
yen this was this was a 900 yen and i pulled the tawny
sticker i
all right anyway that's everything i wanted to talk about
for the trip like i said it was a great experience um i
think but i do miss just hanging out with you guys and
streaming and everything but i hope you guys enjoyed the
stories the fun like the fun stories the photos i'll show
like the stuff I bought later in the next stream um and I
can't believe I yapped for almost six hours bro I I mean
it's been a while since I've streamed so I'm like letting it
all out
but I guys enjoyed hanging out with me um next week I have
like it's semi planned um I'm gonna do I want I'm gonna do
like there's this game I saw a lot of people playing there
was like retro store simulator um it's like those video it's
like those rewind video like it's like bhs takes store
simulator so we're going to need that on monday uh sunday no
stream but monday there will be a stream not so tuesday will
be overwatch rank i'm back at it guys i want to say i can
get grandmaster i don't know top 500 the challenger score
system is so fucking ass i hate it it's like it's basically
like how much you play the game it's not really like based
off of uh like rank actual ranks um your ranking but it's
based off of like time you play so like i don't think i can
get top 500 i think i can get grandmaster i'm literally like
masters two right now so um i think i it's pretty much
possible i almost got grandmaster last season that was me
just doing my placements um um and then after that uh i
don't know when but we're gonna start halo 2 that next week
we're win strong we're gonna finally start halo 2 next week
i'm gonna do a single player maybe halo 3 i'll do like
multiplayer i just want to enjoy the story i i don't know i
just want to play it solo for now and then play multiplayer
for that and like in the future um but halo 2 will be me
solo run um and then um what else what else that's all i
have planned so far i'll figure it out for the i'll figure
out the rest later never played halo 2 like i said i've
never played any of the halo games before like i started
with halo 1 and then um and then uh you know you know i'm
just gonna start you know start start learning more about
halo as we go along so that's all i have planned for next
week um is co-op good for halo 2 guys or is is it only halo
3 that's more co-op I remember I asked this before, but I
already forgot the answer.
Pastoki did not write this down.
I end up with a single player.
For Halo 2 and 3, or it's just, uh, Halo 2 solo.
Okay.
Halo 3 and 4.
Okay, it's co-op.
Halo 2 is two players.
Three is four.
Most likely, I'll make Halo 2 solo.
solo uh i don't know because i i it's hard to like really
find someone that's never played halo before too because i
like i want to like i don't know i want to experience it
like myself type deal and also someone that wants to like
learn more about halo as well so i think i'm gonna do halo 2
solo for now and it will go into co-op and halo 3.
anyway guys I am going to call it here, everyone.
It was been a fun time.
Just, you know, hang out with everybody, chatting, showing
you guys all the...
I took so many photos.
I took 400 photos.
And I think I only showed 20.
Like, I took 400 photos and, like, photos and videos.
And I only showed 20 of them.
You know what?
It's fine.
anyway guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check
get up and move around to get that blood flow and if you
stay up for me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see
you guys next time everybody it's great to be back guys bye
everyone bye